[Music]
shout out to our sponsor blue man they
have been uh
working with us for a couple weeks now
honestly i've been using the [ __ ] out of
it
so you guys always ask me how the [ __ ]
do you do your hair your hair is proper
trust me it's a [ __ ] accident every
time honestly really
garbage at doing my hair but this [ __ ]
actually does help it hold
there's like six different kinds from
blue man different strengths this is one
of the stronger ones
so this is how i do my hair every time
and once i get to this stage i feel like
that piece of [ __ ] from uh
the green mile that stepped on the rat
that's how i feel
percy so guys since this is the pre-roll
ad read you get to see what we do every
time
and yes this is the episode with og so
get [ __ ] ready
honestly guys i've been using this for
weeks and i've noticed my [ __ ] is
looking pretty [ __ ]
proper and this is it right there
i push that [ __ ] forward push it back
almost done
so that was officially our first
pre-roll ad read this is blue man you
guys have seen him on our channel before
uh you guys ask all the time now your
hair's proper as [ __ ] shout out to your
barber
shout out to my [ __ ] barber and
if you watch me on snapchat instagram or
any other day
i don't look like this at all i only
look like this when i'm filming because
every other day my hair is just [ __ ]
but the past two weeks guys i've been
getting up doing my hair trying to look
proper when i go to the bank and look
like some high-ass [ __ ] once
again before you leave guys go to
www.blueman.com that's blue man
b-l-u-m-a-a-n
slash yola that link is in every video
description that we have
so once you go to the website or you
click the link in our video description
it's going to take you to a page on
blueman.com and that's just
the stuff that we mainly use but
remember at checkout when you're
checking out with your credit card use
code yola y-o-l-a and you get 10
off so guys get ready for this episode
this is my homie og we're very good
friends you guys have been asked for him
so many times
so this episode is finally going down
all right guys i hope you're as excited
as i am
let's get to the episode
[Music]
what's up everybody dopaziola here
thomas whatever you want to call me
thank you for being here on another
episode of the dope as usual podcast
we are here to talk about drugs
accomplishments life problems and
everything in between in no particular
order i know i [ __ ] it up every time
guys i am going to get straight into
this
guys today is an episode that you guys
have been asking for non-stop on my dope
was yolo channel you asked
do more videos with og on my instagram
do more videos with og more dank calls
more this
so guys this camera shy [ __ ]
decided to get on the podcast
oh gee what's up uh what do you want to
call you oh gee or what your regular
name
you call me o.g all right og with two
e's
all right here we go what's up dude here
you go what up man i'm glad you're here
camera shy ass dude appreciate you
um guys i'm just gonna hop right into
this i got questions he hasn't seen any
of my questions
if for those of you at home or on the
radio that don't know this is one of my
very good friends
so this is gonna be more of a [ __ ]
talking episode all right we're gonna
just talk [ __ ] and say stupid things
it'll be all right it's just like we're
in your garage all right and just
remember we're in your garage
just pretend that there's stuff
everywhere all right and your daughter's
trying to smoke all your weed up
all right we're in your garage all right
here we go guys um
first question man where'd you grow up
he's telling
elaborate how was it growing up are you
still like well
i mean what you're born 76 obviously
right yeah 76.
so you're 10 and 86. so i'm assuming la
gang life is starting
yeah yeah well actually just my cousins
were actually starting
not you you're 10. no i'm just a kid i'm
i'm seeing my older cousins and
you know my actually not too older but
you know a little bit you know
it's five years apart exactly and i'm
seeing you know what they're doing and
you know that
they're with that gang and you know
three flower hair flowers
uh touching their pants creasing them
down and
you know i mean all that [ __ ] all that
mexican game maker [ __ ] hair knits
and all that
the hair nets yeah you know hair nets
were still big back there you know i
mean they were still
they were in little shower caps yeah
right do you know that yeah
everything man [ __ ] was just popping up
and i still didn't have no clue what it
was
i'm thinking i'm still seeing something
that's just normal you know i mean
nothing out of the ordinary you know
everybody you know you know that's what
i'm seeing you know i'm growing up i'm a
kid
[ __ ] it you know me and for everyone out
there you grew up on the same block your
entire life
yeah yeah the same don't say your block
but you set up the same block your whole
[ __ ] life so you've seen the changes
of l.a oh yeah from your front door yeah
for sure
what 45 years on my blog
damn so i mean i've seen it all since
since little too big i mean
[ __ ] i mean in those 45 years i must say
no that i must have dodged about [ __ ]
about over 30 bullets
guarantee you know what i mean for
everyone out at home
you were not into gangs whatsoever as a
kid your older brother and your older
cousins
you're guilty by association yeah
actually yeah that's you know i mean for
me living in the neighborhood where i
lived in it was
i always no matter what i belong to that
gang because you know that's where my
family was from yeah
even though you're just doing your thing
yep no matter what you know much as i
tried
being that casual kid riding my bike you
know not minding my own business
i'm not from no gang it was still like
nope you're from there too
and jumped all the time get beat up
jumped or you have to you know start
running away or start you know what i
mean there was no no other thing you
know you just had to
like at 10 years old you're getting
chased away uh
no no i said it must have started about
must have started it's this started
probably about
1990 1989 oh so you're like 13 14 ish
i want to say about 12 yeah 13 about 10.
it's just hitting you i mean from her
said same [ __ ] doesn't matter how old
you are you hit up yeah
12 13 is just let's say you know i mean
i i started actually
you know okay liking a little bit you
know it's more i was still like you know
you're about 12 you know more or less
i'm not every 12 year old but you know
my age about 12. i was just still like a
little wannabe which you you wanna call
you know i mean just
but you're still doing good kid [ __ ]
yeah you know i mean at the same time
you know i wanna i wanna address you
know i wanna carry that you know
that you know that coaching my family's
caring you know i mean you know the
tough look and [ __ ] you know
so at the same time you know i'm kind of
you know i want that but then i'm like
nah you know it's not for me
but then i started seeing that you know
no matter what it was just it was just
following me like no matter where
where i went if i walked to the liquor
store they were there
if i walked you know over here they were
to a park they were there
you know what i mean it's just like nope
you're from here no i'm not from nowhere
i'm not even from there you know my
brother is my cousins are you know me
no no you're from there there it is you
know what i mean
just automatic stomp out a little kid
yeah [ __ ]
whack [ __ ] yeah i mean so eventually
i just had no choice i was like you know
what you're in that [ __ ] you know what i
mean i might as well
join them you know what i mean because
you know getting forced into that [ __ ]
well not and actually forced for
protection almost
well what do you think say it was for
protection no it wasn't for protection
your brother's beating
hold on was your brother a cousin
[ __ ] fools up for beating your ass
uh well yeah they would i mean of course
they always took care of me okay okay
that was no matter what they always took
care of me
but at the same time you know i mean
after a while you know we got a little
older and i'm just like you know not a
little older but you know i started
hitting like
14 and i was like you know what [ __ ] you
know i'm getting beat up i'm getting
chased by this you know i might as well
just join the gang
i mean i have no choice you know i mean
i'm i'm getting beat up i'm getting shot
at
so just going to school getting shot at
uh
not like not at school but mainly in the
neighborhood you know i mean just trying
to when i went to school you know it's
kind of more you know
it's a little different at the school
you know not that food
back then it was more like people would
carry knives and [ __ ] like that so you
know i was still with that you know i
mean
you know it wasn't too crazy in school
stuff you weren't carrying a gun yet
no i wasn't still playing again you know
nothing like that you know what i mean
but um
[ __ ] just it's just life at that point i
think i feel like you just got
you you are like i said product to your
environment you're trying to be a nice
kid and you just keep keeping your ass
warm so you join the gang
i mean basically yeah all right that's i
mean yeah i'm not choice
it's okay expect it yeah i mean and not
that but i mean [ __ ] i mean i was i was
in private school so you know i mean
it was just way a little more different
you know i mean that was my next
question did you guys grow up with money
because you told me you were in a
private school but it's a catholic
school so did you grow up with money or
did your dad just hustle his ass up to
get you into a good school
shaving my dad was that guy that just
worked 24 7. you know
14 16 hours whatever it was he did it
you know what i mean
he put you at school for a reason though
yeah i mean my mom never worked the day
in her life he always supported my mom
you know i mean
you know i mean straight up you know i
mean it was just damn the male house
took care of everything you know i got
you so he was just that strict guy you
know
he was totally [ __ ] anti-gang all
that [ __ ] bro but
his son's a gangbanger oh yeah but i
mean [ __ ] [ __ ] we went through our [ __ ]
man we went through yeah whooped your
asses huh i'm telling you i mean
i'm yeah he would whip our ass for sure
but i mean [ __ ]
rip our clothes up you know i mean if we
had pants
you know and everything anything that
was big size anything
get cut up he tried shirts t-shirts uh
white t-shirts he'll cut him up you know
what i mean
he knew right away you know i mean damn
your dad's down as [ __ ] cause most
people don't even
[ __ ] try oh bro yeah his favorite
[ __ ] was you know you come home and he'd
be like you know what
i don't want no statues in front of my
house you know i don't need these clowns
right here
get the [ __ ] out of my house you're just
literally just chasing oh statues full
standing yeah christmas
here you don't call the statues i don't
even know damn statues get the [ __ ] out
of my house you know what i mean
and he'll literally you know we'll be
like [ __ ] let's take off you know or
right when they just literally hear him
coming down the street they're like
[ __ ] we're out of here you know i mean
your dad's coming i mean you just he
didn't tolerate that [ __ ] at all
so he tried man i'm gonna say he really
did he did try you know i mean [ __ ] you
know but
you know like i said you know once
you're in a gang and [ __ ] like that i
mean
you know it's a commitment you know i
mean you're more scared of the people in
charge or than your parents at that
point
yes right and trying to try to get more
scared the streets because now you
kind of belong to the streets you know
you're from a gangster that's like you
know what i mean but
same time you know i mean we still had
that i mean by lisa and i know that my
days
we still had that respect you know yeah
no for our parents for sure for sure i
don't know about now
the way it's going now it's the same
[ __ ] man people are dicks people are
nice it's
the same [ __ ] um so for everyone out
there surprised as [ __ ]
you went to private catholic school yep
yeah from one age to what age
let's see i got so
i believe it was i was in public school
in the beginning and then i started
came to some trouble actually i was
getting bullied you know what i mean
and um you know i just figured like [ __ ]
i think i gotta do something i hear
you know my brothers and my cousins
talking about this and that how they
handle [ __ ] they just you know
hit somebody over the face and do some
crazy [ __ ] you know what i mean so
you know i had i kind of wanted you know
i was like you know this is what i
probably got to do you know
yeah so you know i believe so you know i
believe wait chef [ __ ] up right there
you're fine
i'm telling you dude when you [ __ ] it's
okay he'll cut it but uh you can keep it
rolling but i [ __ ] my words up
62 times go [ __ ] let me say that again
all right y'all so
okay so what it was is like oh wait just
start here
go you're a catholic school and you
figure you see your cousin's whooping
people's asses so you're like i'm gonna
start whooping ass and then i got in
trouble with catholic school
just start from there i'm telling you
it's just fine oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] no i know i know you're good so
basically we'll start here because marty
knows when to cut
um you're at catholic school just start
from there so
start like this so i'm in catholic
school i'm probably like 10 years old
and then just tell how catholic school
is
okay okay so basically i was in what i
was in uh
let's see i was in i wasn't so first
they put me decided to put it in public
school i'm in public school
you know and uh [ __ ] come third grade i
had like this crazy ass teacher you know
i mean
[ __ ] literally whoops our ass you
know what i mean
give us spankings [ __ ] oh it's the
70s and 80s still they could still beat
your ass right yeah this was still 80s
yeah my mommy's got her ass whooped at
school she took yeah i know and back
then you know my mom would literally
give permission to the teacher like
you know what if he ain't doing good
pull him by the ears you know
that was yeah that's you know public
school
yes you know [ __ ] my mom was like the
straight mexican bystander she didn't
give you know
she was straight with the old school
[ __ ] you know what i mean she believes
so she allowed them to know
yeah she would say if you don't listen
you'll give him a [ __ ] give him a
[ __ ] whooping or something
like that you know what i mean and
believe me man [ __ ] one time i did get
it you know i mean i pulled a chair out
on this kid
he fell back hit his head and man little
kid started yelling like he over
exaggerated you know of course and
[ __ ] i remember that teacher just got me
and whack you know what
put me in the corner and i was in the
corner like [ __ ] you know
and so this day i mean [ __ ] i never even
told my mom you know
did she beat your ass no and you know i
mean just
i knew i i backed in and you know [ __ ]
back then if you go home and tell your
mom
i think you get your ass whipped again
you know what i mean i mean
it depends on what you do but back then
if the teacher's allowed to whip your
ass you're in the wrong
you did something for the teacher to
beat your ass yeah that's what mom's
gonna say yeah yeah you'd get the double
whooping
so you just don't say [ __ ] you don't
[ __ ] it you know what i mean so from
there
you went to school yeah from there
that's you know i started getting in
trouble here and there and
getting a couple fights and you know
before you know you normally go you know
what
put on no my dad goes you know put him
in private school you know just because
my sister used to be in private school
so younger sister yeah no no my older
sister i don't know you're
just resulting yeah you're a few years
older than me so they put me in
private school just you know go out
maybe that'll help him you know because
it's your older brother
no my brother no actually he got away
with it not going to private school you
know what i'm saying because they were
like oh
lost cause he's a gang banger let's try
to fix [ __ ] og no actually he still
wasn't a lost cause it's just for some
reason my brother got away with it bro
you know i mean the first morning they
just
you know they love him bro he's little
you know
he's a little key you know but you see
the opposite prince of their families
taking out on the [ __ ]
first no they they he was the one that
that got to do whatever he wanted to do
if he didn't want this he didn't have to
do it but when it came to me and my
sister the middle and the last one we
were [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
you're going to private school so you're
in private school how was that
i mean it was i thought i mean [ __ ] i
thought it was better than
puppies i thought it was a lot more
funner really i mean was all boys
no it was girl boys and girls so why is
that more fun
school it's [ __ ] i mean actually i mean
well the thing is that
you're growing up i mean you're you're
going with the same class for the same
people
throughout the whole year so it's like
almost like a family like you know it's
almost like
camaraderie [ __ ] brothers and sisters by
the time you're like so you know i went
in at third grade by time we were like
in
seventh grade [ __ ] we were we were
[ __ ] like brothers and sisters like
we knew each other so that well you know
yeah yeah
that's cool actually yeah you know what
i mean and [ __ ] it's like
if you know one girl turned around and i
got hit in the head because i smacked in
the head or i pulled her hair
you know it was just normal it was
nothing big so basically you're saying
i didn't get as much trouble in catholic
school because nobody wanted to snitch
on their brother and sister
basically that's what i'm hearing from
you that's pretty crazy i mean [ __ ]
we would i mean i think it was a lot
more worse i mean honestly
i learned more from private school than
you know
so we're public school you know what i
mean oh yeah they're good you know what
i mean yeah for sure dude
i mean they taught us a little bit of
religion and all that which kind of i
guess
i felt like you were the badass kid in
school i feel like you were doing some
dumb [ __ ]
that smile tells me i'm right i mean
the hesitation i'll say this man i got
kicked out of private school for
actually they said that i ran the whole
classroom
like you know like a gang they said so
you know you're running the whole
classroom like
everybody's literally listening like you
know like you're a sergeant everybody's
just like
you know everything you're trying to do
they're doing it for you you know what i
mean
and you know yeah they kept you out it
was it was pretty much you know i mean
but i mean i wasn't doing it in a bad
way just
i mean that's just the way we would all
you know hang around with that school
like
you know we would all say like hey you
know because basically you know you have
the you have the eighth
you have the sixth seventh eighth
graders right so if we're in the sixth
grade
you know basically our rivalry is always
at seventh grade that class right above
us yeah so throughout from third grade
we grew up with that same class always
right next to each other
so we always had that little hate and
then we had that you know that little
peachtree time when we have
next you know we have that hate and then
it's you know so throughout the whole
seven years it's just
back and forth back and forth you know
what i mean so i was
you were a bad kid you were telling them
to do [ __ ] the teacher wouldn't listen
and you say something listen
well basically yeah i mean because we
would i mean these guys would try to
bully us so my thing was like no
you know i i've been i was bullied when
i was a lot younger and i didn't
tolerate it and i knew how to get i knew
how to get myself out of it
so now that i was in the seventh grade i
was like nah you know i had now we're i
mean
now we're in seventh grade you know
we're a little older so now it's like
time goes now
we're going to handle [ __ ] like this now
i mean so you're running a gang is what
i'm hearing
it was a group of like-minded people
that are ready to pull violence if
possible i i still remember the
principal
telling me that they you know when she
pulled me in there and she had my mom in
there
and um so it was all about you know like
i had gave everybody names i gave
everybody a nickname
you know this is called the gang so so
basically you know
everybody wrote on the damn bench
everybody wrote their name
you know you hear this and uh
so the next day i pulled up the
definition of gang and he's just reading
it out of wikipedia
i mean i mean i wouldn't call it a gang
because it's not a gangster yet but i
mean it's our little gang in our little
world
in private school it's pretty much what
i what i'm hearing
so i mean yeah so i remember the
principal called me and hey so you know
what um
i'm hearing that you know you're running
everybody you know you can
you know you have you know you're like a
sergeant here you're like
everybody listens to you everybody's
just like you know like
so they kicked you out yeah they kicked
me out i mean
well what happened was the name was
written so the teacher came this one
this one dumb kid out of everybody in
our whole class you know he decides you
know to put
call himself regular or not we can call
you this no i'm
chris oh he put his real name so he
wrote chris on there so you know so when
the principal came and seen that
she thought hey so who wrote this and
we're all like we don't know she thought
who wrote then she went let's go and
we're like
well i'm just like whoa i don't know i
mean she's like who's
this who's little baby joker yeah so
like chris and we're like well
well we're after that once she said the
name she figured out because he's part
of
he he sounded a little bit different
like a c-r-i-s
or something like that oh yeah so when
she figured it out like we're all like
oh [ __ ] what's there we're good [ __ ]
[ __ ] she figure out who didn't know
you know somewhere like
cool so they got that one kid chris you
know [ __ ]
suspended him and [ __ ] and no do you
know he went back home and you know told
his mom everything he snitched on yeah
he's the one who told his mom
everything what went on what i do or how
everything's running the whole program
sure and um that's what it was ah
he got one weak link that's all it takes
marty
one
yep because they killed the [ __ ]
that does that oh just like wow i
couldn't believe it i was actually
pretty shocked i was just like [ __ ] all
right you know what i mean
yeah [ __ ] it you know what i mean but it
was what it was you know i mean i
actually ran into dude
a couple of times after that you know i
mean it doesn't matter i was a secret
you were a kid
you know i mean it's all good you know i
understand how the way it was but there
was
against a little kid i mean maybe are
you good but
we'll see yeah um so just to stay
chronologically right here
i know a lot about this man's life so
i'm trying to [ __ ]
throw things out that i've known over
the years real quick
can you tell me when you got
when you moved out of your house you
were [ __ ] 14
right uh i want to say about maybe 13 or
14
you left or your mom and dad said get
the [ __ ] out no actually you know what
um
my breath so my brother had a kid at a
young age she was still in high school
he was a senior he had a kid
and of course you know i mean we didn't
have the biggest house you know i mean
you moved out for that
well we had a two-bedroom house and you
know what i mean and my brother had a
kid so my brother had his kid you know i
mean [ __ ]
i mean that's that was like the golden
child you know i mean
your parents made you move out because a
baby no no no not at all but
at that time when he had a kid i had a
girlfriend you know i mean i just got a
girlfriend
you know kid [ __ ] you know i didn't
think nothing of it i mean [ __ ]
i thought it was just all right should i
have a girlfriend no problem you know i
mean no biggie you know me
but i mean it just turned out a little
more hectic
after that you know not hectic i know
but your brother your brother had a
a kid so you thought there's not a lot
of room i'll move in with my new
girlfriend
no actually uh so my brother yeah my
brother had a kid and uh so i had a
girlfriend and then uh
you know we just the house was too
crowded you know what i mean
you willingly left the house at 13. no
i'm not willing and not that they told
me oh you gotta leave or anything
but i mean my so my girlfriend's parents
you know so they were drug addicts you
know what i mean
and um you know they would let me stay
over you know i mean they'd be like yeah
sure you know you could stay here your
second home sleep over you know what i
mean yeah sure
you know and they were cool i was like
oh [ __ ] you know what i mean here i'm 13
14 after you know 13 or 14 and then you
know next thing you know my parents are
like oh yeah go ahead you can stay over
there you know what i mean
they're cool you know what i mean but
that's because at the same time you know
i mean i had my little nephew
that was still a little baby so they
were just like they're overwhelmed yeah
they were like [ __ ] they love their
little butt
did your parents know they were drug
addicts yeah they kind of did
you know they did damn your parents were
just like yo take him off our
daughter you know what hands please what
it was it was actually the gang [ __ ] was
starting already to hit a little heart
so they figured since you know they were
gang members they were
actually ex-gay members as well drug
addict parents yeah you know i mean so
at the same time i think my dad felt a
little more safer like saying you know
they'll probably take care of him a
little better because gotcha maybe
they'll teach him a little something a
little [ __ ] up
but i get i get it yeah i get it it's a
little [ __ ] up but i mean not that i
mean [ __ ] i mean
i mean you're gonna like your son so
much people tell me i mean i'm totally
grateful because i'm gonna rest in peace
i mean if it wasn't for them i probably
wouldn't be in this seat right now with
you
you did probably be in jail or probably
be dead or you know something like that
i guarantee you so you move in 1314
you're dating their daughter they know
obviously in the room she lives in you
live with
so they're letting they're like hey go
back my daughter
don't worry totally cool they were
actually more that type like um
you know it's like uh it's it's more
like well
if you know i don't want my daughter to
be out there with everybody you know
it's more like you know you know this
guy seems like a nice kid
[ __ ] instead of you know what i mean it
probably was the right thing to do back
then because i mean [ __ ] you know i mean
she could have been with any other guy
and you know who knows like yeah
was she the same age as you yeah we're
actually uh
she was uh yeah actually when you're
younger than me
or a couple months younger than me so
maybe 13 shows about 13 too so yeah
gotcha got you we're about the same age
so you move in there and they're drug
users
so does that mean you're allowed to do
drugs there yeah
for sure everything you wanted man
really not anything
i'm gonna say we're gonna exclude you
know some things but
most part yes whatever we wanted to
experience our
experience with and try out yes really
yes for sure
were they doing drawers with you oh no
no no
they did their own [ __ ] yeah they did
their own [ __ ] at their own time like
that but
you know we would do our own like say we
want to hey you know we want to try out
um
crack you know sure you know so
try it out try it out you can just you
know chill right here in this room i
don't want you guys taken off nowhere
and you know and yeah we'll try it on
that's not
i'm i'm not going to say they're bad
people at least they know like you know
you stay
like we're under supervision you know
anybody like you know they were they
were pro so they knew exactly
your designated driver for the house yes
you know they were actually pretty cool
you know i mean
they took care of us i mean so what'd
they teach you the guy the guy was
turning into like your mom they were
like your mom and dad
basically when you left i mean they
taught me a lot of [ __ ] man i'll be
honest they taught me the hustle
you know i mean they taught me you know
the principles you know i mean
you know you don't do nobody dirty you
know what i mean you always
take care of principal you know this is
what it is you know i mean
so it always it was always that you know
i mean anybody here you know you ask for
something you better make sure you pay
them back or you come with their money
you know i mean so they they tell us the
whole hustle game you know i mean sure
started selling weed and
there was morals and gang banging back
in the day right yeah founded on
principles and should
yeah oh yeah that works yeah it was it
was pretty tight you know i mean and
back then you know they didn't have
camera phones
no cell phones camera phone all that
[ __ ] so you know i mean it wasn't like
you know
you have to worry about somebody
recording it was like [ __ ] it was open
season man [ __ ]
[ __ ] went down any split second you know
what i mean yeah i can only imagine back
then too
oh yeah i brought you it was it was
pretty local man so
and you told me a lot a lot about them
before so they told you they showed you
how to break
down wheat is what you're doing yeah
break down the weed wait out and
you know and then they would come people
like oh hey could you friend us and then
they would give us the
you know you confirm you better tell
that he better have your money and you
better make sure that you know
him so he they literally you know they
taught us the ropes you know how to
the hustle and everything you know i
mean were you paying rent there no
no i mean [ __ ] i was a kid damn damn
they're [ __ ] dope but you know what i
mean my parents were still cool and my
parents would actually even still look
like oh here's somebody
you know because they knew that i would
stay there so you know at the same time
i knew you know my pups
no matter what you know he would always
still hook him up with paper you know
i'm like yeah oh here's some money you
know like
on a friday or something like oh here's
somebody you know here's 100 bucks 200
bucks
you know i know you got this you know
taking care of my son yeah yeah i mean
yeah yeah they were cool and they seemed
that i was kind of like i wasn't
because at that time i was already
starting to like wonder like [ __ ] the
streets well you know what i do you know
i want to go to the streets i want to
you know have a girlfriend what i want
to do so they were like no [ __ ]
have a girlfriend you know we don't want
you in the streets so you know
but you know even though i mean [ __ ]
they were cool as [ __ ] you know i mean
they were gang members themselves so you
know i mean from east l.a
uh yeah from east asia as well yeah so
they show you how to break down winnie
they teach you all the rules to be a
good [ __ ] business person is what i'm
hearing which is dope as [ __ ] how long
were you there
[ __ ] i was there so i was there for
maybe about 13
about till i was about 17. what the [ __ ]
yeah your whole high school life yeah i
was there
did you like this girl i mean yeah i
mean for sure i mean i was a kid you
know
no i'm not gonna say no i mean [ __ ] for
sure you know i mean [ __ ] why
am i gonna lie about that but i'm saying
you know i mean no [ __ ] yes
how different would you be if you hadn't
done that what was that how different
would you be if you hadn't done that at
that point in your life if you
stayed at home [ __ ] you know what i mean
like i said you know i probably wouldn't
be here right now having this
conversation with any of you guys it's
that seriously you guys probably would
have never even heard of me
oh i mean you know i mean i mean that's
it taught me a lot it taught me a lot of
you know
you taught me a lot man [ __ ] everybody
you know that's cool
that's good [ __ ] i mean they took you in
and taught you did they have any other
kids besides that girl
yeah yeah you know yeah she had a little
brother too damn he had a son too he was
still schooling you up too
yeah hello brother he had a little
brother you know bro was cool as [ __ ]
you know what i mean
he was you know [ __ ] you know like
that little kid you know
yeah no i got you it was [ __ ] you know
well i i didn't hear this far the story
when you told me that's
that's shocking man they were actually
like good parents so then you went on
your own after that you left out of
there and you're just
now well actually you know it just it
wasn't that you know it just
i think honestly i think it was just a
time for me to learn and you know
learn learn something of all that you
know what i mean yeah
because they give you when i got on you
know i mean i
no matter what you know i mean there was
still contact with them or there was
still something that you know
we always kept the cool [ __ ] you know i
mean oh that's cool that's cool you know
it was nothing like you know it was
it wasn't left like on a bad term to say
like [ __ ] you know he did us dirty or
anything sounds like family
yeah they saw your family yeah yeah you
know i mean they were cool as [ __ ] man i
i wouldn't even mind saying that you
know they
they were like family they were you know
i mean you know they treat you i need
the
i need
so question when did you get your first
gun
i know you were a kid so it's long
enough away so you won't get in trouble
uh
cause if you're doing it i i gotta
handle my first gun was from actually
from uh
from the parents of my girlfriend back
at the time when i was at that age at
13.
you know i mean they gave you a gun and
showed you how to sell wheat
actually yeah show me gave me a gun
taught me how to you know use it taught
me how to shoot it everything you know i
mean
god damn so were you not coming up under
a gang by being in this house i mean
[ __ ] it sounds like it was like a
lateral move
no no no they prepped
growing up in east l.a in the 90s and
early 90s
i mean [ __ ] was popping off i mean [ __ ]
was wild man i mean
[ __ ] at that time you got you had the
movie colors come out
and that was that [ __ ] [ __ ] you had
[ __ ] at the show i mean you
i remember i was still a kid and i
remember i went to go pick up my brother
and one of his homies at the show yeah
what show
uh you know michael was uh
it was uh commerce show i believe still
it was
commercial it still is conversating okay
you know you want to go pick up my
brother and he was still
like i want to say what cousins came on
89 or something
i feel like it came out in like 1991
really an exciting one someone really
liked it
i remember pulling up to the show and
picking them up i was still a kid i'm
staying in the car you know
and this was like getting into the car
creased down white shirts
hair nets you know and um we're picking
our brothers he's like damn you know
what i tripped out i was like [ __ ] it
was more like you know when you um i
remember when fast and affairs came out
and you had everybody pulling up in all
their fast cars driving out of the
theater and their fast car
popularized it it was yeah it was like
[ __ ] scarface
everyone thought they were a [ __ ]
murderer and a coke dealer after that
[ __ ]
yeah pretty much you know i'm saying
everybody wanted to be at the man so
when you see colors
when you see [ __ ] blood and blood out
you're like oh no that's our [ __ ]
neighborhood and then you start getting
like a pride even though the pride is
for bad things yeah
for sure i mean yeah so i mean colors
came out and
it just [ __ ] was wild man that just
literally pumped up pumped up and
pumped it up even more for the 90s man
[ __ ] just made it even harder now like
[ __ ]
then you had boys in the hood come on it
was even [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] you had you know drive-bys and [ __ ]
you know what i mean so would you say
if you're if you're a mexican kid
growing up in east l.a are you
automatically at odds with all the south
central gangs and [ __ ] tours
i want to say i mean if you're a mexican
i mean a little mexican kid back in the
90s i mean
pretty much [ __ ] in the 90s it was
pretty tough [ __ ] i mean i want to say
80
i mean yeah you probably joined that
lifestyle that culture you know
i think you're saying like the you're
basically saying like the crips and
blood black gangs versus the mexican
hoodies yeah you like
what's how does that go down like how
does that work but you guys are far you
guys are
driving to shoot each other you guys are
never really leaving your neighborhoods
too right no i mean
no i mean we got our own like say we're
from eastside we got our own we got our
own issues we have only
in east l.a our problems are in east
delhi you know we don't go down to
south central and go vice versa no you
know you got you got south central they
have mexicans
and blacks and i'm pretty sure they're
going at it trying to fight over what
they got
it's the same thing we got our own
little [ __ ] he's starting we're fighting
we're going at it trying to fight what
we got you know i mean [ __ ]
some [ __ ] but that's right that's what
you grow up in
yeah it's like what is it like i always
say it's prison mentality
you wake up video game who can i knock
the [ __ ] out today
it's points it's cool red it's points
it's frat boy [ __ ] in
prison you gotta think about it there's
fools that you can't bang nobody can't
make money you can't do drugs you can't
see your family you can't ever eat good
food
you're gonna
[Music]
my [ __ ] this is my area get out of it
but i feel when you're more on the
streets it's
it's more like it's an open season you
know it's more like the wild west on the
streets and i mean that
was the first time i got shot at first
time legislation legit where you went
after you didn't
after you ran i want to say i was like
shout out
[ __ ] god someone tried killing me i
got shot at i bet i think i want to stay
about
maybe 14 years old what would you do
just walking home
for the same [ __ ] you know i mean
getting accused i'm not getting accused
i mean just get
i'm just you know hey he belongs to that
gang because my family does so it
doesn't matter you know i mean
then you always grow up with these
that's the thing that always [ __ ] me
up as a kid because you know i told you
all the time gangs no i don't know
you explain gang [ __ ] to me because i'm
like
huh what why and you know i know
some dumb reason but that's why he got
shot like what the [ __ ]
so to me you're growing up with these
kids you're in elementary school
you're doing you're hanging out you're
playing basketball you're watching
[ __ ] michael jackson music videos on
mtv it's [ __ ] 1982
and then north one from here and you
shoot at each other
yeah i mean [ __ ] i mean my brother is
right i mean i mean my brother got shot
by his
one of his own friends that we used to
literally take to school
see that's that's you know that's the
type of [ __ ] that i'm saying because
when i see somebody die i think of the
kid version
and it [ __ ] me up like when my homies
die i'm like i think of the kid when i
first met him
like in movies like oh when the kid's a
kid and then he grows up and he dies in
the movie like
the kid is dead like you think of the
kid that you first met
so you're taking the guy to school and
he ended up shooting your [ __ ]
brother
yep yeah i mean they end up you know
joining different gangs
i mean we're still still living in the
same neighborhood but you know yeah
little [ __ ] like that just because it's
like [ __ ] football teams
to the max like oh you like the bills
i'm a cowboys fan
let's go that's like la is different i'm
sorry i'm from i'm from [ __ ] buffs
we did not have this we played gta and
[ __ ] thinking about this [ __ ]
yeah no i mean [ __ ] no it was real man
[ __ ] the 90s were real that's what i
want to say [ __ ] that was real so you
got shot out at 14
your brother got shot at by your own his
own [ __ ] homie that when they grew up
yeah he got shot when i was probably
about 15 i believe
and then after that you're shot in the
ass right
uh no he got shot in the foot but didn't
he get shot in the ass too
no no no he got shot in the field right
in the bottom of the foot
he literally you know got shot right in
the middle no actually when he was
running
to the car to break a bottle with a
dude's
you know face and before he even got to
the car dude pulled out
uh you know 25 and instead of shooting
at him no he did shoot down you know
what i mean but it's still ricocheted
hit him up on oh
could you imagine so when he turned
around and he picked that foot up it
went right in his foot
i mean i'm talking right on like the
stepping toe like on the foot
you ever step on a lego
you [ __ ] you ever step on a lego
here's a 25.
yeah you dad you ever step on us legos
first thing i thought of oh god so your
brother got shot at by his friend
he grew up with just because hey just
the rivalry gang you know we ended up
i know you're in the same neighborhood
you can do this what's up
oh you're another gang i'm gonna shoot
you that's crazy
i mean [ __ ] that's crazy to think like
that oh yeah man [ __ ]
i mean i used to talk to some people at
him before the next thing you know [ __ ]
we're not friends anymore
and that's just it you know what i mean
wow
isn't it usually by neighborhood are you
you're happy people are all different
that's
the same neighborhood well no i mean
actually i we ended up joining a
neighborhood that was
was not in the neighborhood that i grew
up in so we grew up you know
without saying at the time back in the
90s you know it was a rivalry
neighborhood
because we you know we started going at
him you know i mean so you're in san
francisco rooting for the [ __ ]
raiders
yeah something like that i mean that's
that's a bold move i mean that's what
you guys are getting shot at
man yeah i mean [ __ ] like i said we you
know we had we had we had my house
cocktail
you know oh hold on tell people at home
cocktail when a bottle
full of something that is flammable
cocktail you put a [ __ ] rag in it
light on fire when it explodes it's a
little grenade and catch the house on
fire
so for people at home that don't know
what my house cocktail means someone
tried to kill his whole family
so they threw the bottles through your
window right yes explain
so i just wanted to let everybody know
at home just in case you see so i grew
up okay so on my blog i grew up with you
know we
are we grew up with our um our cousins
with my mom's sister okay my mom's
sister got a house right next to our
house
so we grew up together so we grew up
like brothers and sisters you know
sick so when they went you know
we joined we joined the gang right there
so we were considered like [ __ ]
that family right there you know i mean
so our block was always like that
one ghetto with that gang house to get a
house i mean not knowing that you know
our parents were still hard working my
parents wouldn't know my dad the
kids live you know yeah but it was just
the bad kids yeah i mean
the dad's the hard-working guy but his
sons are a piece of [ __ ] yeah basically
you know
so they basically wait you know they try
to cocktail our house you know i mean
like
both of our houses you know who it was
oh yeah for sure okay but you know what
i mean but uh
for some reason you know i mean they
didn't know how to make cocktails
because they didn't go off
you just [ __ ] roll in your litter
right well that same night you know when
they did it you know we're all looking
and [ __ ] we found what they were trying
to do
and we're like oh how crazy is trying to
murder someone's whole family
in their sleep by fire by [ __ ] fire
in your own neighborhood
knowing there's a kid in there that's
crazy to me
i mean [ __ ] there's a wild wild west
so they cocktailed your house and then
[ __ ] didn't happen so you know i mean
from there on you know the wars went on
here and there
left and right that's the whole point
right that's all it is drive-by is the
house getting shot at
you know what i mean [ __ ] must have been
pissed you died you [ __ ] so he i
would make you all leave i think so
every time every time our house would
get shot at
i mean every time we get our house shot
at literally you know
the next day we would have um blueprints
or all that [ __ ] from houses from uh
moreno valley and [ __ ] you know what i
mean we're moving to moreno
so we'd be right there like oh [ __ ]
we'll be like oh that's a pretty big
house oh [ __ ] it looks pretty nice but
we're like i'm down
we don't want to yeah we work kind of
down we're like well [ __ ] that is a nice
house so we're like [ __ ] are we really
gonna move or not
no we never moved you know it was all
just a bunch of [ __ ] that was just
uh
every time we get shot at i'm gonna
threaten my sons and go look at this
blueprints
it's a nice ass [ __ ] white one they
wanted to do it i believe they did want
to do it but
it just wouldn't happen guys that's how
like we got you got it that's [ __ ]
yeah that's that's so that's a sitcom
start right there that right there
little g little kid we really gotta move
we're next to the brady but he's doing
it deliberately
yeah i'll shot it three more times if i
can get shot at maybe
what if i just get grazed in the head if
i get grazed now but you can't get a car
shooting at his own house
oh gee did you ever think about that
like just do some [ __ ] like
just [ __ ] yourself up so you can leave
in a bomb ass house
i mean [ __ ] we tripped out i mean now we
make now we just we we talked about
it we're like [ __ ] remember all those
[ __ ] [ __ ] imagine we would have saved
them we had a stack man [ __ ] because
our house was always getting shot at you
know jesus christ
left and right left and right you know
what i mean her sister must have been i
was getting chased
yeah my sister was like the complete
opposite of us you know i mean
my brother the gang members my sister
was a complete i mean i'm talking the
opposite like
no drugs anti-gangs everything
you know she hated it all she wasn't
with us nothing you know what i mean
[ __ ] you imagine being hurt those are
the people that usually end up getting
[ __ ] shot now yeah
did you but you could imagine being hurt
i'll tell you what i mean one time
we got shot at check this out one time
we got we did get shot i was outside
in my porch and i'm chilling and um you
know um
i noticed this car passing by and
passing by i'm like oh this car passed
by twice already
you know and that's one thing you know
when he's telling i mean why not you
know any good
you know you're on your [ __ ] you know
you're on your toes you see a car don't
you know it's not from the neighborhood
you already automatically
bam okay this car bam you know so i mean
a car was passing by like that and [ __ ]
uh before you know it i'm all you know
this car is coming too slow i'm like you
know what
[ __ ] [ __ ] this you know i don't got no
gun on me at the time so i'm just like
you know i'm i'm going inside [ __ ] this
you know what i mean
so as i'm going inside i hear the
gunshots and next to you know
my sister's going crazy i'm going crazy
[ __ ] yelling and [ __ ]
oh my sister has a line on her forehead
bro i mean the bullet literally
sometimes somehow hit bounced up
went up so she had a scar of the bullet
right here on her head
what so she was like she got burned by
it
i mean i don't want she got burned by it
bro but i mean somehow
she had she had a line right here on her
forehead so it bounced off something
that must have it bounced off
went up that's fine intervention so i
mean [ __ ] it couldn't win
it could have went the opposite way it
went straight up they left there like a
little burnt mark so
she says that it was a bullet because
she's seen she's seen a spark
or something so i ain't gonna say she's
wrong
i mean i ain't neither i mean [ __ ] i
mean you're talking about i'm pulling up
just in front of the house and like oh
she'll tell you letting it off
she was traumatized you know i mean [ __ ]
that was her story from him
my sister she like i mean as it is she's
been over exaggerated
just imagine oh and the bullet went in
but
it came back out and just scathed for
sure yeah the bullet came and she dove
and did a [ __ ] flip
turn and everything so what i did is i
did a backflip into splits and then i
felt
a burn for sure yeah yo so
jesus all those stories and one just
[ __ ] me up
you rise of right now your makeshift dad
the drug addict guy that took you in
gave you a gun showed you how to use it
because people kept [ __ ] with you and
you were selling weed
so obviously you had a gun now then your
brother got shot just a recap for
everybody
then your brother got shot in the foot
randomly then your house got cocktailed
but it didn't go off because you were
the bad they were bad kids in the
neighborhoods they're like
well we know where he lives let's just
go shoot his house up so you kept
getting shot at your dad brings out
every time you get shot your dad
threatens to move
so i have to go through all of this
right yep
he threatens to move your sister almost
gets shot in the head
now what because i am what age are we at
right now
okay yeah i'm still about yeah 15 to 60.
so you would go and hang out your mom
and dad's house even though you lived
here i would really
i would i would still go back you know i
would go of course you know you get in
the fight with your girlfriend
i'm leaving you know you go for a couple
days back home and you know
yeah but not only that but my parents
were you know they always had to go to
mexico you know
so they always had to go back take care
of business over there
so when they would leave [ __ ] it was on
man [ __ ] we're like oh
hell no it just you know little
gangbangers with pistols and drugs
oh did you go to high school did you
even [ __ ] go to school yeah
i mean [ __ ] went to school i mean i'll
tell you this one thing i wasn't that
kid a ditch i love going to school
you never ditch no i was obviously i
mean i smoked weed i mean cut classes
to smoke weed you love going to school
because you ran everybody like a gang
nah i mean no actually i mean high
school i mean yeah my childhood
high school in my childhood school how
does it sell weed so i mean i loved it
because
i gotcha gotcha i mean i was making i
want to say anywhere from
85 to maybe 100 bucks a day
every [ __ ] and back in the 90s [ __ ] that
was that was money man
you're making 400 a day basically yeah
equivalent and you're a kid
in and out like we're talking to [ __ ]
bob and that's the most expensive you're
buying it maybe a little gold chain
i feel like such a [ __ ] not selling oh
you
[ __ ] up i loved it [ __ ] it was the
best man i loved it
it really was i don't know it's not all
right look
it's like bob the dealer for the
interview it's a [ __ ] disease
don't you find it i know you don't sell
dr by the way og
runs a legal dispensary he doesn't sell
drugs anymore the biggest one
he doesn't sell drugs no more so i mean
i i mean
i never sold drugs i'm gonna be honest
with you it was weird i've always hated
i've always i've never i was
always against drugs like the hardcore
drugs to sell
when i was younger maybe about 15-16 i'm
going to say i did i saw crack
for a minute yeah and after a while i
started seeing
i mean that we were getting addicted to
the crack my own family was getting
addicted to the crack
like i said wait wait a minute this is
not right right here like i'm selling
crack but i have my cousins
coming and buying you know next thing
you know i'm over here putting it
smoking in a pea dog putting it with
weed you know what i mean yeah
same [ __ ] you know what i mean so i go
wait this is not cool that's why i kind
of i you know i took a little
step back and away you know i can't suck
crack i mean [ __ ] who am i gonna sell to
my number one customers
gonna be my own family because i live
here on the block with everybody yeah
so you know i said you know what i gotta
find something else you know that's
gonna be you know
and i've always i was telling weeba at
the time i still didn't think weed was
as you know as big you know i mean i
didn't have to clientele
as much you know so that's when i
started saying hey you know what maybe
weed and
next thing you know [ __ ] i started you
know
getting more into weed and [ __ ] that
just [ __ ] blew up for me you know i
mean
yeah it really blew up for me like
everybody in high school just
wanted it was in demand and i was like
[ __ ] so
luckily i had a friend you know one of
my friends rest in peace
um same thing you know he had he had his
packs you know his brothers were the
ones that had you know they they had a
lot of [ __ ] you know i mean they
they didn't pack some high school so i
can get packs anything you know what i
mean
so i started getting packs from him you
know you know my boy started bringing
you know what i'm gonna give you this
um this pound right here you know
[ __ ] kilo whatever it was you know
back then i still didn't it's actually
no [ __ ] i don't all i know is it looked
like a brick
and it was more than a pound you know
just like a big o so from that you're
like [ __ ]
you know you know you just start
weighing it out just way down we had a
little hanger back then
start waiting oh to do the scale yes
a few times so the triple beam shot
it's a makeshift version you hate the
manual
right here you take a hanger and you put
a bag like with
weight like what you to counter weight
it and you can weigh
it i've only done it one and it had did
you have the thing with a little dial on
it
yeah okay yeah and it it's it's a triple
beam yeah but it's a one you make
i don't know what the [ __ ] we're talking
about it's a triple beam but you make it
okay so you know so back then [ __ ] you
know what i mean three point five or
three grams you know who cares three two
that was a dime you know here you go
[ __ ] it oh cause you're selling brick
weed yeah you know i mean so
what i did so i figured you know in high
school you know [ __ ] started making
nickels you know i mean [ __ ] so i
i started selling nickels because i knew
everybody had the little chunk changed
yeah lunch change
that's what i'm collecting i mean so
[ __ ] nickels
all day long you know what i mean hey
you sell 20 of me 100 [ __ ] dollars
right there
real quick for sure and don't get me
wrong you know [ __ ] sometimes the word
though the [ __ ] bud would be [ __ ]
dirt so
i would have sometimes i would come out
of you know school at the end you know
at the end of the day i'll come out of
school
you know go towards my car you know [ __ ]
because i did have a car also in high
school too
oh [ __ ] yeah so i mean [ __ ] i would
see my nickels
someone literally [ __ ] stick with
that [ __ ] on the one put you know
you know [ __ ] og's nickels
uh five dollars dirt nickels you know
they would be talking [ __ ] you know what
i mean
wow but that's because i sold so much
[ __ ] buttons
on it you know what i mean it's gonna
happen they would literally take the
time to buy one some extra
just to do that you know what i mean and
i would see it i would see it then i'd
be like [ __ ] hell yeah cool you know i
would leave it there you know what i
mean
and you know just wait the stone the
stony little crowd would literally come
take it up and say [ __ ] it you know they
rolled it up and they'll be like yeah
what are they sticking at like literally
just on the like [ __ ] you know like
on the wall like you know yo
the 90s was so 80s was so [ __ ]
wild that somebody a rival drug
competition
weed dealer in school bought a nickel
from you just so they could stick it on
the wand go
dirt [ __ ] sacks from og for sure
and they left it there because they got
money anyway and everybody started
rolling up goes yeah i buy it from him
thanks i already bought one today
thanks so it didn't matter it didn't
matter i had it i had it unlocked
there's no
no it was done daughter you know i mean
she had one time i remember
um my teacher should um i had my wife
krista
pants white shirt and you know she
[ __ ]
she would get mad because i'd be talking
you know someone behind my seat so she
turned around
she got my shirt she literally like
wrinkled it she got and she like twisted
like
she wrinkled i'm like what the [ __ ] and
she like pulled me down and she
literally stalked me in the back twice
what like crazy [ __ ] bro some cycle [ __ ]
and you know i was like what's i got up
i'm like what the [ __ ] you know i mean
so i went [ __ ] i was pissed
i walked out of her class she went
straight to the lunchroom should i need
you to listen to me i'm like [ __ ] you i
walked out of the class and went
straight to the lunch to the cafeteria
and uh [ __ ] but [ __ ] like about
what it was like 16 15 chimichangas went
back to the class
before you know it nobody's [ __ ]
listening here everybody's [ __ ]
eating the
[ __ ] chimney power move i did not
expect you to say that [ __ ] [ __ ] piss
you know i'm like [ __ ] you know i had
the money i was [ __ ] balling man [ __ ]
[ __ ] all the kids their little nickel
bag money on some chimichangas
yeah they wouldn't bought wheat from you
because you got food this reminds me you
saw one eight seven right
yeah yeah we had seven some the whole
scenario sounded like that
yo that's mom that might be the most
baller move i think i've ever heard of
high school so what'd you do when you
walked in with [ __ ] 15 children
no well actually she was just she was
tripping because she's like what is this
food doing like
here who wants one at first you know you
even had the nerdy class the nerdy the
nerdy students that didn't even want
anyone when they're like no but you know
i mean [ __ ]
i was cool bro i was cool as [ __ ] with
the nerds and everybody bro i didn't
give a [ __ ] what you were bro
i treated everybody the same you know
like i said i got bullied back in the
days too
so i didn't [ __ ] with nobody bro i knew
what that felt like so to me it wasn't
like
i was i can't remember i still had that
that look and everything but [ __ ] you
know when it came to like casual people
i treat them even better like you know
what i mean you don't [ __ ] with them
because they're not
they're not about this so you know what
i mean so like you know so
they actually at first they were like no
you know and after a while i'm like come
on you're not gonna take one they're
like are you gonna take one from me and
they're like
yeah i'll take one you know you're
[ __ ] you're cool you know what i mean
and i'm like yeah you know [ __ ]
and next thing you know you got the
whole class eating your rappers
everything and the teachers just trying
to talk and just [ __ ] piss like [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did you do and i'm just
like [ __ ] it so i mean my burrito knows
i'm like so what were you saying now so
you know we're listening to you now oh
you're a [ __ ] dick
in the best way possible she got off
easy though
i mean dude she pushed you twice i'd be
i would've did she [ __ ]
i mean it didn't hurt at all bro the
punches did not no
it was the it was like in the move it
was just like how she did it but
i use that an excuse to say [ __ ] this
i'm going to do something yeah that
might be the most baller move ever
i love it clip that's a clip right there
i love it
that's a [ __ ] movie scene thank you
for that a lot of kids don't react like
that you disrespect some gang banging
kid like that they're going to get them
[ __ ] blast you in the face and damn
good [ __ ] you never told me that that's
good you did some anti-spa holy [ __ ]
instead of getting your food taken you
gave everybody there's a lot of [ __ ]
that i'm still just like damn i could
think of i'm like damn [ __ ] oh i did
this
actually today i was talking to my
friend we're just thinking about all
kinds of [ __ ] we stood back in the days
too we're like
wow that was horrible you know what i
mean like [ __ ] we used to just
stump [ __ ] man you know what i mean like
yeah no of course
you got the money let's do it [ __ ] it
you know what i mean
it's pretty cool okay all right
especially having you know some money
yeah and you're in high school you're
just chilling yeah [ __ ]
so yeah you know what i mean i had a
monte carlos
so i think in the tenth grade no
actually in the what kind of monocle do
you have
so in the 10th grade i had a a honda
excel that's what i started off with
you know and [ __ ] [ __ ] it to me that was
like [ __ ] it was your
any car as a kid yeah it's a clean
shotgun
[ __ ] i was popping off you know i mean
and no license no driver license neither
you know what i mean creased up no
license were you rocking a hairnet
uh no actually i would rock a beanie
early in the morning driving to school
so it would be spinning and then by the
time i get to school you know i take it
off and
you know put on my three flowers there
walking to school while
slick you know what i mean so you wanted
to go to school because you were cool
[ __ ] of course you're going to go to
school you know actually even i had
people waiting for me too you know what
i mean like [ __ ] i had
[ __ ] i pulled up to a parking lot people
were like oh [ __ ] stuff's weak you know
yeah everybody wanted weed
how were you doing this is not getting
caught by the teachers they didn't give
a [ __ ] well i mean
like i said first of all for me style i
mean okay so
i went to different high schools so
first i started off in alhambra high
school
i got kicked out of there okay then i
went to garfield i got kicked out of
there
and that's not even it was just a
straight i got rolled in
got thrown out that same because you
know i mean there's some [ __ ] going on
with gangs
so i went to sher to some other on
montebello high school
and then from about high school um i got
kicked out of there
as well and then they sent me i had no
school to go to in the district because
they
threw me in all in the whole little area
i was where i'm from
so they sent me to another school in
whittier so i went to winter high school
and that's where all this went down and
then yeah that's where all this [ __ ] how
were the teachers not on your [ __ ]
though
me selling weed i had to be [ __ ] i'm a
ninja well like i said
first from me started a winner i would
have to get my weed to that school
because from there i mean [ __ ] i can get
pulled over just the way i look
yeah nothing so from there you know [ __ ]
i would you know get my wheel ready [ __ ]
it
hide in the hood and on the front it's
good yeah i mean [ __ ]
get to school before you know it [ __ ]
[ __ ] take care of all
my students and all my my students all
my students
this fool is really running the school
that's some [ __ ] impatience
oh man wow so i mean i'll take care of
you know all my friends everybody people
i didn't even know i take care of
everybody
got you [ __ ] you know what i mean and
um the thing was i mean here was the key
i was going to i'm going to tell you
this right now the key is don't be a
[ __ ] dick
yes you know what i mean because be
respectful
in high school they all [ __ ] loved me
and
the only reason why they loved me was
[ __ ] respect
me because if i didn't have that respect
that i would always give them they
probably wouldn't
of course yeah of course that's that's
life that's everything
yeah i mean that's where i would see i
mean because
[ __ ] i literally got caught literally
got caught you know
smoking weed inside the classroom and
the narc literally took me outside and
before i even took me into the principal
he told me hey
do you got any wheat on you i go you
know i don't now you know i just threw
it out you just smoked that [ __ ] in the
classroom okay so what do you have and
you know
one of my friends at the time you know
homegirl was like oh i got cigarettes
she's like okay cool give him cigarettes
i was like [ __ ] she gave me cigarettes
she'll put them in your pocket i put on
my package all right let's go
went downstairs then came the real
searching part or i need to search you
guys oh i have cigarettes on them
so i mean [ __ ] back then you know what
it was is like you know
every district doesn't want you know
when the more kids you have that use
drugs in your district
it looks bad on them of course yeah i
mean so the less it looks good on the
district you know what i mean
so so you say of course they say by that
you know i mean they'll be like oh
you're smoking figures yeah
for one day i was like oh [ __ ] all right
cool
one day damn so when i already went to
high school when i went back to school
you know two days three days after my
suspension was over [ __ ]
they were cool as [ __ ] still with me you
know i mean they didn't even kill [ __ ]
you know
there i was right there again sally this
was the [ __ ] catholic school
no this was in high school high school
high school okay i mean no catholic
school
catholic school [ __ ] stopped in eighth
grade yeah stopped in seventh grade
but my first sack of weed was given to
me by some girl in sixth grade
in private school oh wow she gave it to
you yeah so she said well
actually i mean dude she has like i said
the 80s were different man i mean this
girl was
she had a boyfriend bro that was like
over 18. and she was in sixth grade
and this dude would literally come and
pick her up from school you know what i
mean
what hold on yeah sixth grade putting
her out like twenty i mean
yeah there's some real [ __ ] and back
then i mean [ __ ] i don't know 80s
no one really even looked at that even
you know oh [ __ ] you got a boyfriend
that drives the car
oh [ __ ] cool whatever you know what i
mean so i guess
this guy smoked weed and um you know he
hooked her up with some buds so
she hooked me up with some weight you
know i mean you know so i was like [ __ ]
yeah yeah [ __ ]
got weak but i didn't smoke it i went
home and i sold it to my brother good
[ __ ]
you know she made 25 and the
[ __ ] didn't pay me for it
so i did something that never changed i
didn't yeah exactly i didn't try it
you got the house shot up and you [ __ ]
me on the weed i thought i sold it but
yeah it was never sold it was just more
taken in my head i'd go [ __ ] i sold it
to him but never paid me
i mean wait so when you were younger it
was your brother uh
yeah he was wait he's older than you
yeah because i know your brother now i'm
like
yeah yeah about 40 he's cool
yeah he's about six years older than me
yeah that's a big [ __ ] difference
when you're growing up
okay because my sister's a year and a
half older than me and that's
a massive amount of time yeah for me
myself
oh yeah [ __ ] it was too much it was
tough you know [ __ ] growing up with that
phil
oh that's why you thought he was cool as
[ __ ] he's six years older
probably having some chick having his
homies they're all dressed creased up
looking sick oh this fool came and beat
me up trying to beat me up what'd i do i
stabbed him in the neck
you getting bullied i'm like damn she's
that's the kind of guy i need to be
you were just you were destined to fall
into this [ __ ] of course
i looked up to [ __ ] adam sandler yeah
that's all i looked up to everybody at
school i'm like no my mom said she'll
kill me if i [ __ ] hang out with you
fools
i'm out and that's why i was never
everybody's gang making around me
i never once stepped foot in it it was
local man [ __ ] it was crazy
that's [ __ ] it's just what happens who
do you who's around you to look up to
yeah you have nothing else to do i mean
it's just you become a you know a
product of your own environment
of of course bro you see that and
especially creased up
pants and that's just hard i mean but
you can't wear it it's like you know
what
i mean you can't expect to say well i
mean you'd expect me to be a doctor
because
i mean i don't hang around with um
doctors kids
and you know i mean i'm not around that
you know i mean so it's like
[ __ ] i'm around [ __ ] we are guy right
here you know yeah of course which is
it's everyone everywhere for sure yeah
and every you know you know
and that's just what you know you become
you know i guess
are you more likely just i mean you can
go with the floor i mean
not everybody does goldbeam it's a two
percent do something else everyone else
usually just chills and does the same
[ __ ]
that the parents did like what is it
like i'm gonna work at the coal factory
like my dad i'm like
no why don't you leave like why it's
that mentality like why would i leave
like we were talking to fabian alamo
and he was saying like his house was the
drug house you grow up like that you're
in it
you're automatically in it your kids are
in it you don't think it's bad you're
gearing
yeah yeah i mean it's a slow ball effect
once i mean like they say
once you're like once they got you
already like
stamped as that in the hood your stamp
does that bro yeah you weren't even
opening nobody will ever look at you
differently
that stays on you no matter all the time
like so this day we're still
that that one family that one
five years later the older fools are
still looking at you guys so no i mean
like i said we got our neighbors you
know everybody that you know i mean [ __ ]
we got our neighbors
from all down the street and everything
i mean to this day we're still
considering og moved across the street
from his
parents house by the way they got the
whole [ __ ] block on luck
how many houses on that block six uh
five four
four four and they're all touching bro
it's compounded bombs across the street
across the street
yeah don't pull up there so we all look
out at each other i mean that's
the gang thing i mean because no i'm
saying like pull up gang banger [ __ ]
there because they're not
they're not with it it's like the your
normal cousins and then your mom and dad
that are normal
and then your other uh cousin they're
normal like they're like i mean it was
just basically i have a truck and boots
it was more like it wasn't more like it
wasn't like a a
thing like my my my dad and my
grandfather you know i mean because
you know you do got now you know you got
you still have you know like
gangs that you know families that have
trades down from like the grandfather
was from here and yeah
the mom and the son you know like that
no more or less was more like you know
we had to it was just like our parents
straight from mexico
to us and us gang members so we're still
like yeah you know we're in between that
you know i mean like
so it didn't turn out that bad because
you know we put a stop to it
you know now like our our kids and you
know
yeah your kids are normal kids but
how active is that neighborhood you grew
up in now versus back when you're
growing up in it
i want to say it's still about the same
man damn it's depending
on the seasons you know what i mean and
what you're doing too because i told you
when i first started chilling like
yo am i cool right here all right i
asked him like am i
am i good because i'm always smoking a
[ __ ] joint in my car
i'm nice like am i good like no you're
fine it's different
and i remember i was bumping i was like
put i had some song on the card
you can't bump that kind of [ __ ] i was
like some old classic car show music
no you can't be bumping that [ __ ] i
remember he said that you can't
yeah don't be bumping like that turn the
beatles off no not the beatles it's fine
i'm talking about [ __ ]
you know what it was like some del
phonics or something
like [ __ ] he comes certain parts down
olympic and [ __ ]
and this will be bumping all these and
[ __ ] you know what i thought well look
bro when you're coming certain down the
areas
you know i try not to bump that [ __ ]
down go by these areas
bumping that [ __ ] driving and go kiss
[ __ ] you know you could get confused
just because this food was raining hot
and you're not going nah that that had
to look doesn't look good
not even that hold up stay on the main
street at home and i always go to the
same gas station
the same gas station i go buy his house
all the time off olympic
i'd gone there 500 times and i finally
told him where i stopped he goes where'd
you stop
and i go oh my god what this is like
time 300.
i'm like uh the gas station off so and
so he goes
don't stop there no more at night don't
stop there no more
stop stop getting gas i'm like i'm fine
yeah i'm like damn i'm okay all right
but he told me
where'd you start how many people i know
got killed at that gas station damn
at that and i'm like because the first
time i pulled up i went
hmm somebody could pop up right on the
other side of those pumps regular gas
station and la is sketchy
because i you don't you know i'm
paranoid as [ __ ]
every time i leave somewhere i make sure
my park is like accessible i can see
everything around me
but that gas station there's so many
places just to pop up on somebody at
and i didn't think about it bad until
you told me and then i
i kept going but i don't go there now
but still i had a white honda civic
smile and smoking weed i i felt okay you
know what i mean i didn't have a
straight bill hat
i had no kind of teams on my shirt i
wasn't wearing red or blue
man people don't give a [ __ ] about
nothing yeah i know but i i always hope
that
nowadays it's just i just i hope like
you don't got people dressing like gang
members nowadays it's true skinny jeans
and dad hats
now like you know little [ __ ] we used to
call them pretty boys back then yeah we
just didn't
[ __ ] with them you know now you got
these guys dressing like that with
backpacks with beards
you know with all these little fancy
colors and [ __ ] you know what i mean and
you wouldn't even suspect that they're
gang members and those are gang members
yeah i mean
so i get it i get it i think it's the
vibe too and plus
when you when i told you what gas
station his face was like
what i always ask like am i cool because
when i started
when i really first started coming uh
when i first moved down here started
hanging out by your house a lot
i was there like every day because when
i first moved here i wasn't really
doing as many i felt like i was just
experiencing like just chilling in
l.a [ __ ] and this fool hadn't started
the
done the dispensary yet so that's why
we had hella time that's why i get past
like am i good what's up with these
fools
hey this car passed by like three times
it's [ __ ]
it's like merced on on roids
he still is pretty wild i mean it's cool
it's chill
that's pretty chill for the far most it
is you know what i mean it's chill
everybody knows everybody no matter
no matter if you're from this
neighborhood in another neighborhood you
could be from the opposite complete
arriving neighborhoods
but everybody knows somebody everybody
knows everybody right there it's just
one
one way everybody's connected one way or
another it's not like you were
because look at for everyone at home
that thinks i'm like so you just brought
like an active gangbanger on here
you weren't you were only doing that
[ __ ] when you were a little kid yeah
this was actually [ __ ] we're talking
you know what 20 20 something years ago
you know
yeah yeah so it's not like this fool's
just over here being a gang member i
wouldn't be hanging around this guy and
trying to do that
i mean [ __ ] changing i mean
not that i'm not saying you know that
doesn't make me that i'm not still from
the gang you know i mean
that never never leaves you know what i
mean but i mean
[ __ ] you grow out of that you know i
mean and yeah
you get into other things you know i
mean in life you know i mean you know
what i mean like i said
oh at the breakup once hey you said you
wanted me like 62 times and you're gonna
hate watching it all right start back
then
no keep it going no edit keep it going
ready go you're never not gonna from i
get that i understand that
but let me know i'm trying to explain
that i mean i mean again
audience [ __ ] once you join the gang and
[ __ ] i mean there's no i mean i can't
walk out of it i mean [ __ ]
i still am who i am you know what i mean
but you're not out there being a gang
member for the past 20 something years
no of course i'm saying for the audience
so they don't think that oh no for sure
officer sees that and sees oh he's an
active gangplank no i wouldn't be
chilling with og like that he just
smokes [ __ ] weed and
does weed stuff lifestyle's over with
you know i mean
one thing i do always carry the look
though i mean because [ __ ] that's always
been my look
and you know i've always wanted to prove
everybody wrong you know i mean from
from back before me you know people
would put me down and say you know what
you're a loser you're nobody you know
you're so you still look
because my looks i mean they were
literally because back then you know on
the night you dressed like this you know
you were like
you're right yeah you're a loser you're
a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
gang member whatever you know i just
call this regular mexican guy clothes
a hat and logs it's california yeah yeah
it's never going to change
i mean no i don't call my [ __ ] like some
kind of like a certain look what i'm
just saying no i'm saying i always get
away with your dress yeah you know i've
always kept my mic i always kept my
steel on me no matter what
just because you know [ __ ] i've always
wanted to prove everybody wrong you know
to this day
[ __ ] i still prove them wrong you know i
mean i still look the way i look [ __ ]
yeah guess what i'll still eat being at
the same restaurant you're beating yeah
next to that doctor next to that lawyer
being the same food as he is
yeah you know what i mean i'll be having
the same wine as he is too
you know what i mean well i'm dressed
like this but not i mean
but but a couple months ago at his
birthday
oh [ __ ] almost eight nine damn last year
last year he has when everybody was
wearing the mask this fool decides to
rock a [ __ ] bandana instead of a mask
so he's pulling up in a [ __ ] beamer a
nice ass car with a [ __ ] bandana
with the straight bill had locks on and
goes people keep staring at me
so why do people have folks keep staring
at me and i go
are you [ __ ] serious look at you
you're looking you're going to rob me
stop
he wears he has a he's like you know
it's medical you know and then he rocks
it right here
when he's not have it on his face you
know what i do around here
he sure has phony got a knife or nothing
i love it
i love it but you always say you get
[ __ ] mad dog and cops look at you
like
of course they look at you just cause
you have a bomb ass card now i mean
they're not gonna not look at you i look
at you
i mean i was judged so much bro as as in
heist it's not judge it's attention do
you want the attention take the rag off
and put a regular
normal guy face mask why do you think i
rock this look sometimes when i used to
take packs
well no i mean it'd be different don't
get me wrong [ __ ] we're not doing the
pack things i mean
man look the same this guy's just not
looking at these guys
i had a you know uh an ny hat on no
actually you know i would i know you
know when i would be delivering my packs
you know what i would throw my white hat
you know that was my thing i always have
a white hat like caucasian white or like
a you know with some like
round glasses not even like low type of
glasses i always had like
some casual looking glasses she just put
on an orange
and look like a worker i mean always
work for me you know i mean
orange vest bro look like a worker or a
painter yeah yeah but back then still
we didn't have the vessels still they
weren't still there the orange vest was
still too much of a
popular job where like they were oh okay
he's working like now you got everybody
wearing an orange vest
so now it went past like now i would
wear an orange vest but
do some [ __ ] you know i feel that but
back then no it was an orange dress it
was more like
you had to have like a a company shirt
like a budweiser shirt or a [ __ ] a
workers jacket yeah like some company
that was big that said you know bam
had a patch right here that would be
like oh [ __ ] he's going to think i'm
working i'm working and [ __ ]
yeah let me go i mean call the company
shirt
exactly because that's why i'm bringing
it up because this will last year's
birthday
i keep getting mad dog of course you're
getting mad talked i tell you every day
stop wearing the [ __ ]
but there's just certain times where i'm
like damn we can dog that a lot today
you know [ __ ] i'm good
you don't smile you drive like this
you got lokes mustache goatee
[ __ ] they look like you're
looking at them
that's what they think yeah they're
looking back like this
there's no expression you look like a
little homie out of the [ __ ]
machine
of course they're gonna look at you like
oh he's grilling them thinking about
them grilling him
and they're like this like i hope he's
not staring at me that's what they're
doing
nah well maybe you scare people
[ __ ]
i mean [ __ ] i try not to i know i'm just
saying you look normal like a normal guy
you gotta stop wearing that bandana
around your face you look like you're
about to pull out an uzi in a movie
[ __ ] i can imagine now i mean [ __ ] you
know what trips me out is me
[ __ ] walking the 7-eleven and right
before i walk into 7-eleven i'm putting
a [ __ ]
face mask on and share ski masks i feel
like a bank robber yeah
[Laughter]
you know like [ __ ] nobody [ __ ] did
that [ __ ] like i was like
you're
this [ __ ] his favorite thing to
do and it pisses me off because he
always embarrasses my ass
he likes to look at his foot look at him
look at him look at him the guy at
7-eleven [ __ ] he hates og by his
house i mean when he walks in
he gave him a dirty ass look and i go oh
he really does hate you this whole
light's a [ __ ] joint
look at him terrorizes him he [ __ ]
loves messing with this guy he puts it
in his sweater pocket
and when he goes to get his drinks he
puts it back in his pocket
and i'll be we'll stand in line and his
whole jacket's smoking
and i go bro he knows it's you because
he told him he caught him smoking in
there one time
he likes he loves to do it he'll light
up a joint when we were at denny's
this [ __ ] lit a joint because we
were getting hella bad services to start
smoking it
under the table but when they came by
they were looking for smoke and he plays
it off so
[ __ ] good nobody ever thinks it's him
because they don't want to scare him in
the face because he looks scary
sometimes sort of accuses him of him
i just did that at dodger stadium
yesterday he did we went to the game
i'm like just come on just wait till we
get out we have mass on
we have match you're not going to be
able to just hear
this always embarrasses the [ __ ] out of
me but at 7 11
he does it on purpose and the time that
i went the guy was just staring oh gee
checking his things out that's like some
guinness world record [ __ ] embarrassing
dope is yolo with weed
no it's just too much it's more like bro
stop smoking in their house in their
[ __ ] business he doesn't like it
that's for me like i'm so polite that i
don't want to like i mean
i'm sorry sir you're walking through
these places and they don't go far
they're smoking cigarettes bro
but not that that's seven of us are so
disgusting and it's the same guy
it's the same kid you're the one in my
neighborhood
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] nature
but bro he has it in his pocket like
this and it's toying with them though
that's the funny part is [ __ ]
with them i like to [ __ ] with this guy
his face and [ __ ]
yo remember remember perfect example
remember goodfellas
were uh where uh they're talking
uh robert de niro is talking to wow why
am i spacing so bad
ray liotta remember ray leota and then
the feds are watching
robert junior and he goes hold on i like
to [ __ ] with him yeah and he walks up
wake up [ __ ] holes
that's him i like to [ __ ] with them keep
them on their toes
that's his mentality with everything no
no [ __ ] him
how much is it you [ __ ] i've walked
out of stores
i've walked at the store oh geez mine no
that's friendly though cuz he could in
his mind
you could just walk in there take what
he wants and walk out that's it no
you're a business person i think he's a
dad
people get intimidated with my look that
they just you know they just don't say
[ __ ] at times
i mean i'm not saying a year ago two
years ago i i went to vegas
and i stayed at the cosmic and uh you
know went downstairs to gamble and [ __ ]
and uh me and my girl when it could
gamble
next you know i mean i thought it was
like free drinks if you're gambling
right
so of course i'm over here you know
throwing a few hundred and my girls you
know
things that we [ __ ] you know she's
playing but here you go you know [ __ ] it
so he so we're winning uh coupons the
same little [ __ ] whatever they are
little vultures that say [ __ ] free
beer
another free drink good [ __ ] so she as
they're coming out i'm going to say guy
hey here's a free drink for me you know
i'm drinking and drinking it
before you know it he's [ __ ] pissed
bro and like i'm not going to get a
drink he's like
all sudden he's shaking he's all like
i'm not going to give you no more drinks
he goes
he goes here he goes well he says you're
punking me he says what you're doing
he goes he goes i know what you're doing
he's like you're punking me and i'm like
parking you probably never even said a
word to you but just give me a beer and
go how is that punking you
he said i can't give you free bears only
her you're not the one playing
you're just standing next to i go well
damn bro all you have to do is say
something
i mean yeah [ __ ] oh because that's why
because you're look the way you look
just the way i look
it was this fool was giving me free
beers free beers and after finally he
just looked at look there like [ __ ] that
like i had enough for you
like you're you know you're oh he was
just scared you know i mean i'm like bro
how did that how is that even possible
you know i mean that sucks i even said a
word to you so
from there i think you know that was not
even that was basically recently i think
i started when i started just thinking
to myself you know what [ __ ] it's just
probably my looks now
[ __ ] yeah it's not like you're over
there being mean to people ever i've
never seen you be mean to any anybody in
my life
i'm just saying stop wearing that
[ __ ] bandana let's circle back
you got to stop rocking around just wear
masks wear a little mask it's like a
couple more days
it's over bandana good that was actually
my favorite bandanas
it was a raw bandana but it's from far
away it's just a [ __ ]
printed [ __ ] bandana and it looks
gang affiliated
i'm gonna have to ask joshua another one
i have one right [ __ ] there you go
seriously i got you
wait yeah i don't got [ __ ] i don't know
about no rags
i don't have nothing well seriously i
[ __ ] hate you'll be [ __ ] mass bro
i've been
struggling for the past month and a half
okay hold on
i got way off topic let me hit a point
real quick let me tell everybody about
the first time i ever met you in my life
oh [ __ ] we won't say names we won't say
what we're doing
but i'll tell them the situation i
walked into og's i got introduced by
some other friend that sucks now
we're introduced by sucky shitty friend
and um
i walk in and i know i've seen them on
instagram right i've seen them on
instagram and saw a picture of him
because you
you uh post a picture this [ __ ]
posted a joint this big
let me state this right now the only
person on the planet i know that gets
higher than me
all the time for no [ __ ] reason is
this guy oh
it's a hundred percent i'm not saying if
we went toe to toe for dads i wouldn't
whoop your [ __ ] ass because we would
i would i would murder your dad
come on for you leave soup okay it's
like you know what
it's like it's like it's like when uh
let me hear it let's see
it's like you know when chavez fought
oscar i was just about to say it's like
tyson like giving it up yeah
you know what i mean you know when when
you know travis was [ __ ] badass at
what he did yeah
but you know i mean austin ahoy was a
young book that came here with a little
more of that engine
and you know i just okay charlie's gonna
keep up no more with it because you know
just a little
so i might give it to him still but i
might not but you know maybe right now
yeah like i've been a weekend
he respects that you know i mean i've
been very weak at my game so uh
i could say i have been seeing this food
lately the way he smokes
the past two challenges has been really
in this school yeah i mean just like the
other day when i came we're going to
dodge a game this was
[ __ ] i was almost throwing up though
nearly almost like what's wrong with you
i'm like what the f i didn't believe i
thought he was drunk
you know because she's like oh she's
drunk he's drunk and i'm like drunk
well we drunk i'm like oh [ __ ] two grams
of dabs and 26 minutes what was it
it was 2.34 it was a i was supposed to
take some out i forgot
i was supposed to make it two grams on
the dot in my head [ __ ] i don't i don't
know if i could see
it was bad it wasn't fun i tried i mean
don't get me wrong i've tried it maybe
about a month ago tried taking a big-ass
dab
not the same huh oh [ __ ] you still
smoking shattered rising though
oh [ __ ] no no shattering okay good
because this boy used to slap that bra
so the reason i bring it up i'm saying
for everybody out there let me
re-reiterate
if it's just what are you doing smoking
a seven gram joint with hashing it like
for what
i'm bored that's this guy because
that's just that's so there's only one
person i know that just
actively smokes more weed all the time
for no [ __ ] reasons this guy
so for saying that the first thing i
ever saw was him in front of lapd car
with a push trees [ __ ] sweater on
it's like 2013 i met you
and he had a joint maybe this [ __ ]
big like that
i go who is he and then i
met and my other friend said oh i know
that guy so when i came to la to visit
before i ever moved here i met him and
he um
i went to i went to that picture yeah
i wanted to meet him so so you found you
found
his channel on youtube because no
youtube yet it wasn't
youtube yeah we were already following
each other where i was already i
followed him from that
like and i'm like no this guy is getting
[ __ ] up
that's crazy and i'm i went to go meet
him in la
and i'm like i'm in east l.a this dog
barking at me
this gate yeah i think uh your cousin
snuffy was out there
oh where the [ __ ] am i you forgot your
[ __ ] pushed dude that's how i felt like
training
yeah [ __ ] man i am with the white guy
from east coast
maybe i'll be okay because i never met
him before and plus
that's where i'm from but i'm like i
mean that environment but not like
it's an environment i've never been i
don't know my way out when i get to the
freeway i don't know what i'm doing if i
had to run what neighborhood can i run
to without getting shot or
it's not where i'm from so i'm like [ __ ]
okay so we opened the garage and the
first thing is a sign on the door that
says
be shot or some [ __ ] used to have
that gun sign right there some
i open the door go [ __ ] this door has no
way
i carry a gun because cops are too heavy
or something something like that yeah
but then there's a door a wall and the
door has no handle and go
there's only a handle inside [ __ ]
and then he opens the door and then
we're in the garage that you guys see in
all the videos and [ __ ] where i end up
chilling
but i walk in and this was bumping the
cranberries
loud
yeah is he really bumping this music
right now
i love it but like i didn't expect you
to be pumping
yeah i know actually that was my girl my
girl was in there before so she was
bumping me down we bumped that show all
the time it's underneath
i mean no
i just didn't expect it so i walk in
and that's the first time i ever met him
that that's when i went
all right cool it's different now
and then 21 savage came out and you just
haven't stopped that's what we'll put on
the same 21 savage album for four years
straight
he bought a pinky ring because of that
pinky ring song i know it [ __ ]
pick it right a lot of your daughter and
this one bought it expensive
no no no no i've always wanted one so i
know
but that song made him do it i promise
what's up guys i hope you're enjoying
the episode so far i know
og is a fool i [ __ ] know you guys
should be 100
used to manscaped on this channel
already as we said before this is a
trial
everything went so well everyone loved
the manscape everyone used the code
manscape [ __ ] with the ads
so guys we are officially signed to the
end of the year that's thanks to you
guys thank you so much for me and marty
we [ __ ] appreciate it
to my right your left you will see it
yes i we said it before this is these
are ball wipes if you feel like you need
to
wipe your balls hey these are ph
balanced all right i know it sounds wild
like you're battery you're selling ball
wipes
yeah yeah we are to my left your right
is the lawnmower 4.0 this just came out
guys
so if you're new to this channel or
you're new to manscape this right here
is a mail grooming tool
girls have them all [ __ ] day there's
like 60 [ __ ] commercials for razors
and this and that new technology but
this is the first time i've ever seen it
for guys
so let me alleviate some of your
concerns this is skin safe you're not
going to cut your dick open you're not
going to cut your balls open all right i
know we say that explicitly as [ __ ]
but that's us it is wireless charging
it's
[ __ ] waterproof all right so you
could take this in the shower and not
worry about ruining it
also for all you blind [ __ ] out
there there is a light on this thing
okay it can't get any easier
so if you're an active dope as usual
podcast watcher right here is usually
where i put the box for the smooth shade
kit for manscaped
that [ __ ] is sold out 100 so shout out
to you guys
so if you want to know where to get this
go to www.manscape.com
yola if not click the link it's in all
our video descriptions there's a link
right here in the youtube description
spotify apple whatever you want to do
it's there
it's manscape.com yola click that link
and you get an
automatic 20 off plus free shipping
remember that www.manscape.com forward
slash
yola or click the link in our
descriptions so once again thank you to
our sponsor manscaped you guys thank you
for supporting thank you for everything
back to the episode
pour that drink
ah this bottle is [ __ ] cool looking
all right so let me see that cap the
next segment
right now we're gonna pull up for you
this is called who were you in the 90s
basically i'm going to ask you a
question you pick between the two
options
that's it easy as that
i'm [ __ ] high i forgot we already did
that part
all right sorry for everyone on spotify
we took like a two minute break to get
these shots ready
so let's just go into it this is called
who are you in the 90s take a shot first
ding
oh he's not hearing that [ __ ] he's one
scary sound effect
uh no chaser for you you're a monster
i can't do it i have to drink water no
it's good tequila
when it's good i believe you need no
chasers i drink water after
i don't want that taste lingering all
right ready who are you in the 90s
everybody at home
everybody listening in the car if you're
on youtube what's up you can see this
oh that shot's hot okay ready who are
you in the 90s i'm a bench
like i said before easy as that ready go
vh1 or mtv
wait a minute
who were you in the 90s and i'm going to
ask you questions
1992 og yes i'm gonna ask you questions
and you pick
based on you in the 90s what would you
have picked
does that make sense like if you're in
the 90s i'm like three flowers or
hairspray
oh [ __ ] that three flowers yeah that's
the kind of questions
that's it yeah you sure you got it all
right here we go rapid fire
vh1 or mtv uh
90s i want to say uh mtv
boom there we go adam sandler or jim
carrey
in the 90s okay i still love him too
okay
tupac of biggie smalls and no west coast
east coast [ __ ] i'm talking about
music
biggie smalls love tupac
big small is the hardest [ __ ] though
ready step by i don't even know if you
were you watching the move
tv in the 90s yeah okay step by step or
family manners
uh family matters yeah good [ __ ]
pulp fiction or forrest gump pulp
fiction
there we go okay all right pennywise it
the clown or chucky
check mario or donkey kong
well mario okay good well i was like
don't call me super mario brothers yeah
you can't can't knock it full house or
saved by the bell
bro that's a tough one but i want to say
saved by the bell me too
mcdonald's a burger king 90s for sure
for mcdonald's yep
it was the [ __ ] when we were kids [ __ ]
that place now but it was the [ __ ]
michael jackson michael jordan there's
two babies weird thing called the value
pack
mcdonald's fire i remember 89 or
49 cheeseburger wednesdays everything
was a lot bigger back then [ __ ] you know
what i mean
mcdonald's was different really i
thought everything was smaller back then
it was still big that train was
definitely smaller in the 90s
for sure okay you ready michael jackson
from or michael jordan
well [ __ ] it's michael jordan bro all
right there you go because you're a
basketball fanatic so this [ __ ]
was on that [ __ ] but he was a die-hard
lakers fan though no
but still michael jordan doesn't matter
what team he's on yeah still
he reigns over teams yeah gotcha yeah
michael jackson
oh you switched up the [ __ ] questions
yo he switched up the question mid
[ __ ] podcast because it was a
different question 10 seconds ago
boys in the hood or menace to society
well [ __ ] boys in the hood is [ __ ]
not boys in the hood for sure but man
society [ __ ] broadcast movie
brought that [ __ ] you know the brutal
[ __ ] like it was
it was no [ __ ] for anybody out there
that hadn't seen madison society
bomb sorry about the ending okay orange
soda
wait you changed it up too orange soda
or chocolate milk but it's more like
orange soda in the 90s versus nesquik
yeah [ __ ] on that's quick oh there we
go all right
that's you and then all right i i i
could have said i called every answer
you were invited 80s and 90s man shows
that's
the [ __ ] bro that little light-skinned
rabbit that [ __ ] was selling
everything what happened to mascots
captain crunch where the [ __ ] is captain
kids worst tricks as dumb rabbit he
could have just took it
he could just took the cereal sorry i
always pissed me off as a kid
like you why don't you let the rabbit
eat that was the thing that pissed me
off tricks are forget
he brought it i don't [ __ ] with you kids
that pissed me off
in the 90s you weren't doing drugs i
figured you wouldn't know none of these
[ __ ]
uh definitive answers i knew he was
going to why the
it's not why it's it's the way you look
it's the way you look where you're from
and how you are nobody expects
because i'll tell them like i don't know
why this [ __ ] fool just references
the dumbest obscure movies that i love
but i would never
think this [ __ ] knows so coming
into that let me can you go back to my
notes
i wanna you don't know about this yeah
i'm gonna tell you something i did a
thing called
[ __ ] oh gee says are you ready
are you ready guys i've known you for
i've known him for a long time
every time he answers the phone it's
something different it makes no sense
it's made up words and i'm just going to
tell you a few things that i can
remember off the top of my head
are you ready jabroni all right
i wrote this down this is a greeting
this is a greeting from emoji you're
saying hi
yolalini yokomodi
what's up mackafellas hi mr rooney
what's up my little meehol he only says
that [ __ ] to me in public because it's
embarrassing
it's embarrassing as [ __ ] i'm like what
the [ __ ] you calling me that for shut up
what's up my little miho okay so he says
all these things to me
is that another ferris bueller one in
there mr rooney mr rooney yeah
all the time what's up mr rooney hi mr
rooney all right
these are og's other words for come over
hey you want to hang out smoke weed
shoot the moon don't lag it this
[ __ ] tells me hey you wanna hang
out all right cool don't lag it
not come over how long don't lag it he's
the latest person i ever met my life
telling me not to like it i love that
i'm always on time [ __ ] don't
lag it
he's eight days late all right so that's
that's come over
all right these are another word another
one this category is called this guy's a
[ __ ]
what a little weasel tits
jabroni little jerk and there's never
anything else besides those three weasel
tits little joke little jerk and jabroni
that's the last thing fool's here
this category is called when oji's wrong
and he knows it
or when he makes hell of money and
there's only one thing he does
when he's wrong and i call him out i go
full you're wrong
or when you make hell of money for
everyone at home
you can't see this so let me do it for
youtube first this fool will [ __ ]
fade away
hit a three like he's really in a
[ __ ] basketball court
all right for everyone at home no matter
what happens if he makes all the money
or he gets called out and he's wrong
he doesn't want to admit he goes it's a
three
all right and that's called [ __ ] oh g
says i'm right
you're i'm not a liar [ __ ] i
wish your wife was right here it's like
no
she'd be like that he does i swear to
god bro
i'm not lying about any of these things
and i know i forgot a lot of them
yeah all right so how do you feel about
that segment man
he's the first person to get their own
segment on this show
[ __ ] oh jesus i swear to god i wish i
could do more
but i can't remember more all right real
quick ready
another topic tell me about your weed
selling days
what did you use to do with the money
when you started making money
go let's see
all right so so what i say so earlier i
said you know i had a friend you know
[ __ ] i had connection
and all that and then you know in
between times there's always you know
little [ __ ] that happens and you know we
can't get it or we don't have it
you know what i mean okay so you know so
um
[ __ ] my mom used to [ __ ] be in mexico
she had to go to tj
like you know all the time you know
every month two months we had to go you
know i mean
okay so you know [ __ ]
i've been teaching now i'm like okay now
i'm
now i'm into weed and now i'm out there
you know what i mean
so now i got you know like me and my you
know compiler go out there
you know [ __ ] we're just out there
[ __ ]
you know let's go hang out with my
cousin out there cool here we go go hang
on my cousin from there
i'm like hey man what's up with the wii
where's all the weeded and you know for
sure at first he's like no
i can't get none and we're like [ __ ] you
know so i'm telling him like
[ __ ] all the goods about the weed and
everything and he's just like oh okay
cool so you know finally then the next
time i go again now he's like oh [ __ ]
you know what i
think i might have someone i got that
wait you were telling me last time
oh [ __ ] all right so there we go you
know we started up some [ __ ] like that
should i get away from mexico so they
see you know man i started
[ __ ] saving you know whatever money
i'm making over here in school and [ __ ]
i'm like [ __ ] you know i'm gonna take
it with me
when i go over there you know so now i'm
taking [ __ ]
[ __ ] five hundred dollars [ __ ] six
hundred dollars
you know [ __ ] with me over there and
[ __ ]
you know i'm in the middle of a thick
this is a poor ass you know
town you know i mean so [ __ ] it's like
whatever you whatever they got you know
sometimes they would have some ugly dirt
weed and [ __ ]
or you know some good ass bomb ass green
[ __ ] but [ __ ] it you know i'll take my
money i'll be like you know what i got
600 bucks what could you give me
and they'll be like [ __ ] you know 600
bucks was a lot of [ __ ] money for
that
now that's a lot of money [ __ ] other
[ __ ] going on bigger than that but you
know for
for me and where i'm at 600 bucks it's
like [ __ ]
you know it's they're they're these
people are like oh [ __ ] they're excited
they're like [ __ ] everything we got
let's give it to him
this guy's like here here you go take it
all take it all you can take it out i'm
like
[ __ ] all right they said you know [ __ ]
i'm going back
you know taking it back to my house we
know that we haven't done tj
and i'm right there [ __ ] how are we
gonna get this [ __ ] back you know [ __ ] i
don't know how to get this back
you know i'm telling one of my partners
like [ __ ] how are we gonna do this you
know
how much how far does 600 go back then
what are we talking about at least five
pack
well i'll tell you what the first time
600 bucks
we didn't take it back all of it
ourselves because it was just too
[ __ ] god
damn because at least five to ten [ __ ]
we're like
what do we do with all this [ __ ] weed
i literally thought i was gonna get like
a [ __ ] pound
or a half pound maybe you know i mean
yeah [ __ ] bro i think i got like about
that i'd say about seven four and a half
pounds
and i literally couldn't even bring it
all back so i literally had to leave
some there
had to like [ __ ] we made i remember
cutting some [ __ ] out for our shoes
i mean we brought it all on ourselves
because my thing was like
you know what um i can't put this in the
car because i'm gonna get my mom caught
up in some [ __ ]
oh she walked it across no no we crossed
so i'm telling this is still before i
was underage i wasn't
over 18 i was still [ __ ] 16 in
chicken
so um i was literally
i would put it on me like [ __ ] it we're
going to carry it on ourselves because
i like in in like suits of it yeah like
like i stuff some of it in my shoes my
sediment bags yeah my shoes my side of
my
legs around my waist just [ __ ] hiding
it on me you know what i mean
anyway to bring it over but i wouldn't
hide it in my mom's car
i wouldn't hide on the car because i
knew that my mom was driving
my mom had no clue this you know what i
mean so
[ __ ] i knew it would fall back and i had
to get [ __ ] probably my ass whip or
i'm [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah so i'm like [ __ ] this so me and you
know wherever i remember
you know we're gonna do it like this
carry it on us and we're going to cross
we'll cross back and [ __ ] you walked no
no we crossed back with my mom because
you know cher
we figured oh you're saying you're going
to have it on youtube
we would just have it on us and just
crossing my mom but in the car yeah
so she wouldn't take that she wouldn't
get trouble she wouldn't get in trouble
like anything [ __ ] they got me well yeah
i mean she does not have no clue as you
can see she's [ __ ] about to
trying to [ __ ] whip my ass or
something you know i get it i get
smart yeah so you know so we would like
cross it
on us i had to cross it on me so [ __ ] it
i am [ __ ] crossing it on me like [ __ ]
i was like [ __ ] yeah you know i got some
through you know i mean like [ __ ] it
she probably got what back a pack and a
half [ __ ] maybe
you know the first time i think i got
back
[ __ ] it was maybe about over two pounds
oh okay okay
cool cool i don't know i'm thinking
three zips three zips two zips
half half step half zip and the sweater
zip zip zip
qp in the back all full yeah
i could use this [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
like uh like if i had a [ __ ] plate on
my
[ __ ] chest half a pound half pound
you cut it you know what i mean did you
have to cut it oh yeah well we have to
break them down and [ __ ]
i would think i would just cut it and
slice like bread and i would literally i
would even go buy a spray can
and should be good i mean [ __ ] we were
still young i didn't know how to do it
i'll be honest with you i was still
[ __ ]
kidding [ __ ] so you know i would cover
it up with a spray can for the smell
cover the smell up with a spray can you
know what i mean
i'll go get some other [ __ ] that i would
think just [ __ ] put it over and wrap
it again and
you know stupid [ __ ] that will [ __ ] by
the time i got back over here [ __ ] i
mean
we had a little [ __ ] smell to the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it must not have been too bad every
time we went over to canada
cars stripped apart everybody out that's
different though this is coming back
into mexico
different times not a band like that
kids regular lady
yeah should go there often yeah cause
you know they keep track of all that
[ __ ]
comes back and forth yeah like oh she's
been here five times this week
let's search your car this time yeah for
sure you know what i mean so they would
search you guys sometimes
oh yeah times that there would be times
though you know they would sense
inspection and be like
[Music]
over the inspection you know okay you
guys know you guys actually don't have
no [ __ ] or
how crazy is it before you smoke weed an
inspection ain't [ __ ]
after you get high once you're like i'll
[ __ ] run inspiration
oh yeah isn't that crazy though okay
wrong i mean later on there was
there was times where you know we were
going we're having no issues with our
own family and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] you know we got you know we
would go visit our family over there we
had other family there and they would
literally report us
yeah like they're driving back with this
and snacks haters [ __ ] haters dude in
your own family
[ __ ] yeah for sure and you know and and
and like for me you know [ __ ] i'm always
one step ahead of everybody know me so
i'll be like [ __ ] that where
i'm like taking no more weed you know i
mean and anyways by the time that
happened
i already had my connect in l.a and it
was [ __ ] more like it was chronic
already yeah
i wasn't [ __ ] stressed no more it was
all about the crime whenever you hear
someone say
green bud they don't know about weed
that means they smoked weed in the 90s
because green bud means something that's
not brown that's what you call that zona
it was on sona oh
you got the zona
no [ __ ] so you got you were smuggling
wee back good [ __ ] you know i was just
bringing i was i mean it wasn't like i
was smoking in like over a pound but
just whatever
hold up
was three zips almost yeah nah [ __ ] i
would get back to school and [ __ ] i was
a man at the high school bro how much
you make off
600.
i must have said i must have made about
five no maybe four racks
so he said four bands at least if you
got it for six and you were flipping
those packs like that
yeah man yeah four bands bro you never
told me that story great
good [ __ ] i love it [ __ ] love it
actually like i said i [ __ ] forgot
about that [ __ ]
that's good and you speak spanish
fluently though so it's a lot easier to
cross
when you're just like oh what's up fool
in spanish and you just
then again you guys look like game
makers and they were letting you across
it like that
well no actually i would have to i would
literally kind of change my look around
okay so what i would do is i would just
change my look around like [ __ ]
regular like i'm [ __ ] working no
actually like the ball was working
you know like just [ __ ] fake pants
freaking you know like beat up big kid
yeah like freaking you know
cool you know i mean good [ __ ] yeah no
about that's one thing i always like to
get my cruciate
[ __ ] keep it low-prone [ __ ] yeah i
mean
she said name of the game is [ __ ] low
pro
that's what i'm telling you man it works
say wear that pizza sign on the top of
your car
keep that job still work at mcdonald's
wear that pad
i remember okay we had a domino's pizza
sign it was a
before i used to be like a like a
sticker and shame we would have one on a
car and
we'd use that [ __ ] for
everything oh don't be saying that [ __ ]
you never told me that that's what i
used to do
i used to deliver pizzas i keep my sign
on after work so i sell sex
no one pulled you over yeah no we had
the little magnet a little magnet in the
car
[ __ ] it yeah we only got one yeah yeah
some [ __ ] like that we did yeah it's
smart it's just it's all about i say we
kept it going i mean i'm pretty sure you
probably had it going like for a minute
but no
here and there like [ __ ] when we had to
do it or something like do a drop
[ __ ] it yeah take this good [ __ ] you
know what i mean i like that anything
you can get stuff in a [ __ ] maybe
even a [ __ ]
any attention away from you is good is
good yeah yeah
having someone with you driving that's
just driving like an [ __ ]
so they get pulled over and you have 10
pack in your car and just keep driving
but cops know that trick on the freeway
stop the cover car the lead car doesn't
work no more
fire patrol's so good with it they're
literally on their microphones
uh red cars lead car okay who's behind
them okay
snatch up that white one that's how it
works so that's i've had many homies get
pulled over the freeway because of
things like that i mean
well like i said when they put us over
one time at the borderline they did the
same [ __ ] they [ __ ]
took us in made us all [ __ ] stripped
down
they had michael stripped down [ __ ]
underwear bro [ __ ] everything
me stripped down [ __ ] everything
[ __ ]
my pager my friend had a pager back then
they [ __ ] literally opened it up
they opened up my pager bro like what
could you [ __ ] possibly having a
[ __ ] page bro
they literally [ __ ] had to open up
wow it was like
they [ __ ] went like [ __ ] they went
thorough
yes for sure bro damn well you went out
from the store i never heard
we didn't have well that's all no good
[ __ ]
that's awesome i never heard that one so
my question was the beginning of all
this
you started selling weeds so you're
making money in high school what about
after when you started making actual
adult money that's what i'm talking
about when you're what did you do with
that
okay well in high school you know i
meant micro you know i mean [ __ ] my girl
in high school oh so you broke up with
the
the girl you were like oh yeah yeah no
that was like i said 17
117 once i got to once i went actually
to
whittier high school i started you know
that's it
cool and all you know i mean nothing bad
just that just you know i just
you said you it was it was fine yeah i
mean my other girl and you know my girl
which is now you know what i mean you
know
you know [ __ ] bro just [ __ ] with her you
know she's been my writer died
all life and [ __ ] you know she's cool
she's with it you know i mean she's
always been with me you know me
and i met her and you know we had a kid
and [ __ ] that after that
it's [ __ ] that was another [ __ ]
episode of my life
so why you started selling weed though
you were selling weed i was already
selling weed
you know the hustle was always in me you
know [ __ ] been hustling
me and my girl i'm still hustling you
know i mean [ __ ] now um and then you had
your dog so now i got a [ __ ] now
now [ __ ] i have a [ __ ] cadillac
a [ __ ] i'm a senior now i got a
cadillac
oh [ __ ] you know still going to school
dope ass kind of like yeah i'm still
going to school did you graduate
uh no no i didn't graduate
they kicked you out no never got kicked
out you stopped going no they let me
stay there till my whole year ended i
never got to stop going what are you
talking about then why didn't you
graduate sir
i didn't graduate but i finished school
till the last day of school
no why damn i had to go to
he was like i love to go to school i
don't do my work that's how you should i
mean i'll tell you right now i mean [ __ ]
dude the vice principal
my dean vice principal they all [ __ ]
love me bro you know
they love me where like you can [ __ ]
chill here because
this whole time i thought you were a
good student this was a [ __ ] never
yeah i mean he was in there every day
faithfully like exactly yeah
yeah exactly bro [ __ ] stood there [ __ ]
yo i didn't know that never did you
whisked it every
day for the one that hit me and [ __ ] but
you went every day and they didn't give
you a diploma they should have gave it
to you at a default
i mean i could have went to the little
extra little dumb class that you know
they sent a little yeah
special class so what do they call
whatever i could have went to that i
could bring one of them
continuation nah you know they got that
little uh when they pull you out of
class and you go
you know to the [ __ ] special class so
you can graduate oh
yeah you know what i mean i could have
been that but i was just more like [ __ ]
that you know what i mean i'm straight
you know what i mean just [ __ ]
straight so you saw me in high school
cadillac had a cadillac meet my girl
and you know [ __ ] before you know it
[ __ ] she graduated and
[ __ ] we ended up having a kid right okay
still semi yeah still said my you know
still [ __ ] being you know
[ __ ] wild and [ __ ] you know i don't
give a [ __ ] but you know
you know she was pregnant and [ __ ] you
know like [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] so you still selling weed my
question [ __ ] oh [ __ ] selling
weed yeah bro that's just
what did you do with the money when you
became an adult what did you start doing
you should travel you should go to
[ __ ] games i know that oh [ __ ]
let's see so when i first well
no actually well when i still had my kid
you know at first i had my kids [ __ ] i
was still
i was still [ __ ] you know a hustler
yeah still [ __ ] you know i'm gonna
say [ __ ]
welfare collective welfare too you know
oh you were the regular old thing yeah i
was still i was still like that
i still have that mentality [ __ ] i'm a
hustler i'm making money [ __ ] i'm gonna
[ __ ] the system no matter which way i
can
got you you know what i mean got you so
i was like [ __ ] you know i want to
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it i don't [ __ ] no i don't know
i had my first name
i'll tell you this you know when i had
my when i had first still had my first
daughter bro i still
right before i had my daughter i wasn't
still so serious bro i was [ __ ]
literally on crack you know i mean when
hold on hold on when i [ __ ] when i
first had my daughter
you know i mean i don't like
how you went around that one i'm gonna
bring it back
rewind for everyone at home crack
cocaine daughter ready go
oh gee can you tell me about the day
that your first child was born
ready go and while you do it pass that
joint
the first day my child was born not the
first day [ __ ] what happened the
day your child
was born the time the event the moment
the
birth the drive can you please tell the
audience
i love this story i mean [ __ ] say it or
else
all right first time in [ __ ] you know
what i'll be honest with you man
nothing changes man still till you till
that first kid is born
before that i mean i mean at least in my
[ __ ] world
nothing has changed i was still who i
was [ __ ] gang member
[ __ ] hustling still selling weed
[ __ ] now i
i was selling crack and i said stop
smoking stop stop standing crack
because you know i was trying to get him
to crack yeah so you know i was smoking
crack as well too
oh [ __ ] i knew that but actively all the
time
uh i'm not going to say an activator no
once a week it was more occasionally
like
on the weekends when it came to friday
after you know you do your hustle
throughout the whole week and once it
came to the
to the weekend once a week it was called
back then we know we partied
and party was that you partying no we're
gonna [ __ ]
you know we're gonna drink beer you know
back then it was partying it was
drinking beer and [ __ ] but
the little extra came towards the end of
the party [ __ ] you know we got some
[ __ ] cracks
and [ __ ] that's [ __ ] getting lit you
know some people get hooked on meth yeah
so i mean gotcha [ __ ] you know i was
still that that's that person was still
in me you know i mean
[ __ ] when my daughter was first born i
mean [ __ ]
i mean i still remember [ __ ] i was
drinking i didn't expect for her to be
born yet
so i was still you know i was drinking
with you know my father you know with my
father-in-law
and [ __ ] and they said you know [ __ ] it
you know [ __ ] i'm getting some
[ __ ] crack i'm
[ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] roll me up a
p-dog
p-dog at home weed makes a crap so [ __ ]
it there i am [ __ ]
roll me up with p-dog and you know i'm
like [ __ ] you know i'm gonna throw some
extra in this [ __ ]
i'm gonna make this one extra heavy [ __ ]
it i'm about to have a child
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] give me that a whole
a whole 20 of
oh damn i put 20 of them all in there
[ __ ] rolled it up i don't think i
even got half ways to it when it was
like
oh [ __ ] the baby
you know your girl she's [ __ ] crying
over here and i'm just like what the
[ __ ] i'm like oh
[ __ ] and the mom's like oh you gotta go
you gotta take her in this net
and you know [ __ ] so there i am [ __ ]
go
i remember i was drinking beers and we
had the beers inside um
inside a big old [ __ ] like a barrel
and [ __ ] with ice
so i [ __ ] went i [ __ ] ran to the
back i got the [ __ ] ice with the
[ __ ] with the water and
started splashing my face and [ __ ] you
really aren't crazy [ __ ] how crazy
you know
and you know [ __ ] tell your truth that
[ __ ] [ __ ] help me out because they
[ __ ] it brought me down it was
so cold like i was splashing my whole
body like splashing so i've got you know
[ __ ] went back inside i drive myself
all right let's go let's go we're going
to the hospital there we go jump out in
the van
you drove yeah so the dad no the
mom didn't want to drive that's at home
he's like [ __ ] you guys hey i know
you're on crack can you drive i'm
drinking can you drive my
daughter he was more like [ __ ] you're
good you you know this is your [ __ ]
you know what i mean you know that
you're just drinking just drink beers
with you
yeah yeah i mean it was [ __ ] driving
my pregnant daughter having a baby
to the hospital kid yeah it was [ __ ]
how far away
so we just you know there we go bad
we're shooting out to the hospital
everyone [ __ ]
driving down [ __ ] you know one of the
streets and [ __ ] [ __ ]
what else they were 11 o'clock 12
o'clock
some [ __ ] like that at night yeah okay
okay
take that back i won't say like 10 at
night okay so you're 10 you're all
right [ __ ] i'm i'm [ __ ] hitting
lights and i'm like
take the light take the light i'm
hearing take the light what i have
taking lights [ __ ] it there you go
running reds running reds you know oh
[ __ ] i don't know [ __ ]
i've never had a kid nothing you were
also on crack yeah yeah that too so
i'm a little over paranoid and [ __ ] you
know what i mean
so [ __ ] there we are you know we get
to the [ __ ] hospital
and they [ __ ] tell us nope well
false alarm you you know you you're just
still not you know certain centimeters
and [ __ ] you know they're like well you
go back home because you know no so [ __ ]
it we're like oh
[ __ ] you know so we go back so they're
like yeah i don't think maybe tomorrow
or something tell me this part there's
like a little fast alarm
we go back they go back [ __ ]
we get back to the house and i'm
thinking [ __ ] [ __ ] no i'm not going to
sleep no more so i start grabbing beers
now
now i start chugging beers because i'm
thinking [ __ ] i'm going to crash out
king and have the babies
tomorrow or maybe the next day they told
us whatever you know
and [ __ ] you know a couple hours my mom
she calls my mom
my mom tells her about oh you should
take a tea and it's going to help you
out
and this man and [ __ ] she takes the
tea and they say you know that [ __ ] his
tea [ __ ] out somehow doesn't [ __ ]
helps her out and a couple hours next
she's [ __ ] ready to go
drinking tea and she [ __ ] yeah
now i'm [ __ ] drunk bro because i'm
[ __ ] pounding beers oh my god
you never told me to continue i've only
heard you got to the hospital you never
told me false alarm
there's no way how am i going to go home
continue the party
so now you're shit-faced don't know i'm
yeah i'm pounding beers in the garage
so now she's really ready to go and i'm
thinking [ __ ] i thought that [ __ ] was
gonna happen tomorrow i was gonna knock
out already
you know because i couldn't sleep
because you know because you know yeah i
was trying to make myself come down so
i'm pounding [ __ ] beers
so so now i'm [ __ ] [ __ ] we're going
back to the hospital
so now i'm driving the hospital [ __ ]
drunk now
now i feel that was so appropriate
oh revving outside good [ __ ] feels
pretty loud going back to the
go you're in the hospital [ __ ] now i'm
[ __ ] driving drunk back to the
hospital now [ __ ] baby so they still let
you [ __ ] drive
yeah i mean now you're shit-faced and
her dad's doing it let's not forget bro
i'm probably at what i'm 22 23 20
22 years old 21 i think you know i mean
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it i think i know it i'm calling
shots we'll understand oh you drove on
purpose
no i'm just like [ __ ] guys michael i'm
driving get out the way boom
where the key is at she wasn't like that
i was actually on the level but i was
drunk get to hospital
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] i had my first baby
girl and
[ __ ] bro that just like it was like
just my first baby girl being born and
just like right there and then the
minute she came on and i seen her
it was like my whole body everything
alcohol everything just
vanished from my body oh [ __ ] gone i
didn't feel
nothing no i didn't feel drunk i didn't
feel anything it's like
something like just a different type of
high you know what i mean yeah
it was like [ __ ] wow you know i
couldn't believe it that i
that i created something like this you
know like [ __ ] i created a human like
[ __ ] i never thought i'd [ __ ] ever
like [ __ ] this is born because of me
so [ __ ] you know that right there was
like a [ __ ]
eye-opener you know i mean and
so you know i carried on i still carried
on after that with the hustling but then
you know i was still [ __ ] with the
you know with the gang banging [ __ ]
still but i was still like [ __ ] i have
my daughter like [ __ ] i was like in
you know that's hard like [ __ ] you know
what do you want you know what i mean
yeah
so you know yeah [ __ ] i'm like yes
[ __ ] reply for a while for
[ __ ] yeah it's free money you know what
i mean i can't get a job you know what i
mean
i'm thinking i can't even get a [ __ ]
job you know i mean i'm [ __ ] hustling
this is what it's all about you know if
i can make money
and uh so [ __ ] got into hustling you
know i got into [ __ ] actually
playing in pools rewind that [ __ ]
like weekend for a while actually you
don't [ __ ] ended up [ __ ] uh
getting myself on [ __ ] welfare
started doing the pool thing what is
that when you start doing the pool
no no no so so i had my kid bro
[ __ ] still had the hustle going on
[ __ ]
decide to get on welfare because i can't
get a job gotcha you know [ __ ]
so now welfare i'm [ __ ] collecting
[ __ ] nine hundred dollars a month and
i'm like
[ __ ] yeah you know [ __ ] back then it was
helping 900
[ __ ] let's get an apartment let's
move on you know i moved in with her mom
you know i mean i never moved back to my
house from
from the point 13 out from 13 i never
went back to my house it was just
[ __ ]
it was just yeah i just moved across the
street
basically yeah you know i mean across
the street
no way oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
that's the day doji's daughter was born
so did you smoke no no
actually no my daughter was still not
born and then i was still like i said
but
we just went from the hospital to nah
nah no we're still half active and still
you know half [ __ ] you know i was a
hustler
ghetto father you know what i mean [ __ ]
it all three of them you know what i
mean
so [ __ ] before you know it i'm like [ __ ]
you know what i mean what the [ __ ] am i
doing myself you know
there's [ __ ] 900 a [ __ ] month
ain't [ __ ] cutting it you know i mean
i'm [ __ ] making more money with
selling weed and [ __ ] you know and
you just give me a job you know before
you know what
[ __ ] a job just landed and it was like
[ __ ]
it's the thing and i couldn't believe i
got a job
and i literally thought i'd stop selling
wheat i was like [ __ ] i'm done i'm not
selling weight no more
i got a job now so i stopped selling we
i'm like nah
i'm not getting more weed you know i
started cutting off a few people and
they were even like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you know yeah i was like
[ __ ]
i got a job good [ __ ] you know and
started working and then i realized like
[ __ ] i'm only making like
[ __ ] 550 dollars [ __ ] 450 dollars
a week
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you know what i mean
[ __ ] this ain't cutting it you know i
mean
not the lifestyle i want to live you
know i mean at least you know i mean
[ __ ] it wasn't even a great lifestyle it
was still
[ __ ] i set up for [ __ ] just eating
that mcdonald's once every friday on the
weekends was still like a big thing you
know
[ __ ] like damn you know you're eating
now i mean
and that's why i [ __ ] it so i realized
you know i think i need to go back to
selling weed
[Laughter]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] ain't working you know
what i mean that straight narrow [ __ ]
sucks
yo i can't wait huh i can't wait until
this podcast comes out
because he's gonna [ __ ] be so mad at
me how come you didn't cut out me saying
no i mean
he's gonna be so mad at me for not being
able to cut out words
he thinks we can really cut out words
like we can't cut out words
what i mean
sorry i i know i know you
that's why i'm like oh he's gonna yell
at me five this one's gonna be pretty
your version of yell at me is like hey
little jabroni what's wrong with you
fool and you fake punched me
[Music]
no weasel he calls everybody weasel tits
all right [ __ ] no well let me know if
i'm saying that i have to clear it
i told him during the break i told him
twice during the podcast
that's all right let me know
i'm fine i think it's i don't even hear
i hear it only because i know you're
going to be so mad
for everyone at home that's not watching
this
no we'll just see some people won't even
get it they probably will just
we won't even hear it i'm just saying
you yeah this boy hates being on camera
it's the first time he's ever done
anything on camera besides dank calls
with me
and the hundred thousand dollar shopping
spree the first thing he ever edited was
that video
when we went up north all right yeah
first one ever
um so you're at mcdonald's i mean here
at mcdonald's you're buying mcdonald's
on the fridays
you go back to selling weed and
actually i go back to selling wheat so
now actually i meet now somebody that's
bringing me now
actually i mean a real connect like [ __ ]
i got the [ __ ]
real [ __ ] like fire now it's a step
up ahead of the [ __ ] chronic now it's
a little bit more time we're talking
kush you know and now we got that kush
this is sonic
two yeah now it's 2004 2002 you know now
we got that kush
you know what i mean so it's like oh
[ __ ] so now i get to connect i get
connected with something like funny and
get connected with somebody on that
and [ __ ] from there on it just [ __ ] just
starts [ __ ]
getting [ __ ] local man just mad
like [ __ ] because your wife tells me all
this [ __ ] he smell like a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's all i hear he smells stupid he's
[ __ ] spending money on nothing
would you spend your money on hotels
[ __ ] oh money [ __ ] spending on whatever
anything bro
whatever you want at the time whatever
we wanted whatever [ __ ]
anybody wanted my friends like [ __ ] it
we got it
you know i mean [ __ ] i was making good
money at the time you know i mean
so i mean so i met the kush connect and
[ __ ] just from there on it just [ __ ]
just blew up i moved out of my apartment
now now i'm not before you know i
started with an apartment with a
roommate
oh [ __ ] yeah so it was like [ __ ] it was
like a
seven hundred dollar rent split in half
and i used to get nine hundred dollars
from welfare
so i would you know [ __ ] it we was
playing the rant and i remember to stay
[ __ ] i would buy myself [ __ ] one cd
one odcd
and i would be like [ __ ] yeah you know i
got the cd because you know i stopped
selling weak so now i can't sell weed
you know i got my daughter
and you know i mean [ __ ] i was all
depending on the welfare money thinking
i was going to survive off
i was trying to get comfortable with it
you know like [ __ ] it i could survive
so you were there fast forward you met
the actual connect started making hell
of money you started spending money on
whatever the [ __ ] you wanted after that
yeah i just blew up
started getting more money and then i
just said you know what well actually i
started making money so that's when i
decided you know what we don't need an
apartment
just you know a little house get a house
and we're looking
we're looking for a apartment and [ __ ]
and um
finally just by coincidence across the
street from my house for my mom just
where he grew up
stuck in and yeah and you know and the
landlord is actually
actually you know a friend of mine since
you know i've been since childbirth
so like of course he wants to rent to
you hit him back up hey man
you don't want to rent me that house
they're going to be a movie now and this
guy was like
[ __ ] yeah you can for sure go ahead you
know and
move right in bro and [ __ ] man that's
when the
[ __ ] whole [ __ ]
kamikaze started yeah it's crazy man
[ __ ] wild
so you just started making money on top
of money yes
[ __ ] paper non-stop because you gotta
remember i know what you mean
[ __ ] don't know what the
kamikaze word i don't know
you have to explain i know what you mean
like go crazy do whatever you want crash
into anything and burn
because you're making so much money
doing whatever you want i get what
you're doing well whatever
[ __ ] so i got this pad and next thing
you know [ __ ] so i first moved in i'm
like all right i'm fixing up the pad
so i'm already i'm starting i'm already
being known for having that good weed
you know
but now i'm moving to the back into the
hood move back into the neighborhood so
now i got all my friends that
know me right this next you know they're
like [ __ ] you got that kush you got
yeah hell yeah there you go boom
next thing you know it just [ __ ]
started this whole big [ __ ]
my garage bro literally it turned into a
[ __ ] shot bro
like a [ __ ] cars i mean [ __ ] my whole
my whole street bro it was literally no
parking for none of my [ __ ] neighbors
bro ever
people were pissed bro like this
[ __ ] like [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on but since i
grew up since
you know as a kid there everybody knew
everybody knew each other on the block
says
we all know each other like from kids so
it's like nobody would call the cops you
know what i mean yeah
so [ __ ] man i had this [ __ ] place
popping off bro
my dad like maybe about a month after i
moved in
he came over my house [ __ ]
piss bro he knocks on my door i'm like
what's up he's like what the [ __ ] do you
have going on
like what do you mean you're in eyesight
from him eating cereal in the morning
bro he's got 40 people walking in his
house yeah he's like
he's always uh i see a [ __ ] car
pulling a car pulls out
he's uh there's no [ __ ] parking for
nobody he's i can't even i have to park
my car inside my driveways up because
i had me at my outside parking is a [ __ ]
you guys i would park in my driveway
[ __ ] the [ __ ] do you complain about it
[ __ ] wild man i'm talking [ __ ] it was
it was pretty wild man [ __ ]
i think i was [ __ ] i want to save back
[ __ ] 2002.
you were making hell of money [ __ ] we're
talking [ __ ] it was some good [ __ ]
chunk of money
also talking [ __ ] chunk
chance [ __ ] i know what you're
saying you gotta explain [ __ ]
well you're not to say numbers just say
you're making a lot of money do you do
whatever [ __ ] you want i've never heard
anybody say
did i want chunks say no i'll be honest
[ __ ] you i mean [ __ ] i was making about
maybe
[ __ ] thirty thousand a day okay
some packs and [ __ ] just uh just in my
garage and i mean yeah
you know i mean that's not the most i
made i'll tell you right now
but [ __ ] thirty thousand a day for me
you
know
and also you guys remember it's cool you
know what i mean it's not all yours to
keep gotta re-up with that money so it's
not all yours
so everybody out there like oh i'm gonna
go wrong it's not like that
the numbers will get big that was just
the beginning that guys i was starting
it was just
and to me i was just like wow [ __ ] 30
000 [ __ ] i only got to give this much
what the [ __ ] what oh [ __ ] let me put
this away next thing you know before i
put that money away it's like [ __ ]
something else is coming again and it's
coming again and i mean [ __ ]
and this was just weed this isn't uh
you mean you have paper where you just
[ __ ] like [ __ ] all right let's go
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it i could treat everybody i could
treat [ __ ] 30 [ __ ] and [ __ ]
to go eat and drink beers and have a
good time yeah his wife told me a bunch
of
dumbass stories yeah i mean like it was
wild [ __ ] is embarrassing
for hella people you don't even know
sometimes i feel homeless
me and my boy you know we see a homeless
person and [ __ ] we'll be like [ __ ]
different i took this guy up
i mean we're talking [ __ ] ridiculous
[ __ ] there was
there was still no [ __ ] about let's post
this so let's go brag about it
just like [ __ ] it we're just doing it
[ __ ] you here you go man
[ __ ] thousand dollars for this
homeless person he's just like what the
[ __ ]
take that [ __ ] you know what i mean this
one is drunk and tips waiters like
[ __ ] ninety percent like yo you gotta
calm down i like that you have to calm
down well i mean
i mean i'll be honest with you i mean i
mean the reason i
i have an answer for that one bro why i
do that
for one is you know [ __ ] i was put
down by a [ __ ] doctor as a kid you
know what i mean so [ __ ]
oh my god so you gotta explain what the
[ __ ] they did to you
i completely forgot what they did to you
you have to say it right now in
in under one minute tell them about the
doctor experience
so okay so as a kid [ __ ] i got put
through i don't know how many
[ __ ] cats scans and [ __ ]
mris and all this [ __ ] because they
said i had a [ __ ] up
bad disc had scoliosis bad disc you know
[ __ ] doctor said i was [ __ ] up that
i was never gonna amount to [ __ ]
because i was [ __ ] up you know what i
mean my back was [ __ ] up i had to be
smart have brains i work in an office
that's it that's all you're ever gonna
do
here i am [ __ ] eight years old nine
years old [ __ ] doctors telling me
that
you know [ __ ] your [ __ ] dreams out
the door and [ __ ]
so you know i'm over here [ __ ] all
right [ __ ] you believe in him and [ __ ]
so
i'm thinking i'm all [ __ ] up you know
[ __ ] it were you hurting
uh actually you know i would hurt
because [ __ ] i would do you know
[ __ ] sports i would play and [ __ ] you
know what i mean i would be hurting and
for anything my mom would be like
mexican press would be like oh [ __ ]
you're hurt take him to the doctor you
know what i mean and my dad you know one
thing
my dad had was a [ __ ] truck driver so
the assurance was [ __ ] you know good
top you know what i mean so this food
[ __ ] this doctor scenario took
advantage like say
[ __ ] it you know and took advantage of
the insurance money so started putting
me through [ __ ] mris and [ __ ]
[ __ ] literally giving me a [ __ ]
volume before i [ __ ]
go into a [ __ ] tube you know i mean
before i go into the mri tube
[ __ ] here you go i'll take this pill
[ __ ] it didn't just stay it was a little
[ __ ] the volume you know with the
little [ __ ] heart in the middle
[ __ ] it right i'm taking that [ __ ]
eight years old bro i'll take popping up
[ __ ] volume
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] all doped out
[ __ ] the tubing [ __ ]
feeling good i'm not gonna lie you don't
[ __ ] come out of there and i'll be
like
my mom be like what do you want i'll be
like [ __ ] a mcdonald's a milkshake [ __ ]
[ __ ] was bomb you know i'm [ __ ]
loaded you know i didn't [ __ ] know
you know
the doctor lied so he [ __ ] [ __ ]
basically he made him to get scoliosis
for how many years [ __ ] for a good
[ __ ] maybe four or five
six years forrest gump [ __ ] right yes
they had him doing all these tests all
these things
he told he explained to me once because
he was billing people she was just
building and
building the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] bank
off this [ __ ] bro straight up
they ended up catching some horrible
class action lawsuit or he just skated
off into the night
what was that did he end up getting
[ __ ] over in the end of this
oh yeah actually yeah he actually lost
his license for a good
for a good chunk of years i guess they
[ __ ] they got him you know oh
that was the only one he was doing it
too you imagine [ __ ] doing it to a
lot of [ __ ]
and this [ __ ] actually you'd be
surprised this [ __ ] right now as
we speak
he's right now in montebello [ __ ]
still there so he just came back
and you know [ __ ] i just passed by
the day and i seen it i was like
oh [ __ ] you know what i mean and i was
just tripping out like
[ __ ] trip out on this food you know what
i mean holy [ __ ]
you know something else you know what i
mean i got him right there you know what
i
mean
something i got saved you know what i
mean doctor office that's what it's
called
i mean it's a little something i got
saved so anyway so back to what i meant
why i have this [ __ ] issue about
tipping people and all that
was because [ __ ] bro i mean the
[ __ ] doctor [ __ ] told me i
wouldn't amount to [ __ ]
yeah and then i had teachers tell me i
would amount to [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] i wear college shirts to school
and every time you take it out you know
take that [ __ ] off
because you're never gonna you don't
even know what that but you'll never see
that college and [ __ ] you don't really
all right cool you know i mean so now
i'm just like
[ __ ] it now when i go to restaurants you
know what i mean every day oh yeah
straight up [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're saying [ __ ] you put that
[ __ ] tip down that's what you're
doing well because at first when i get
there i get that look like oh
this guy you know i mean
and i know you know what they do they
give it like [ __ ] this is cheap
this guy he's going to go [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] you know he probably just
made some money or you're probably
[ __ ] first of the month he's here you
know i mean
so [ __ ] i was always at the
impression like [ __ ] that you're going
to remember me if i like the restaurant
you're going to remember me
that's when i'll be like [ __ ] there you
go 100 tip it's not that
you know what i mean that's not my it's
not what i'm talking no but you do do
that
this is why i started doing that because
from so much [ __ ] it's like
i would i would never use like look if
people would give a you know what to say
those gift cards like christmas gift
cards like for restaurants or whatever
you know
i wouldn't use that [ __ ] man for one
because
the way i look and i pull up with a
[ __ ] with a [ __ ]
discount giveaway card to a restaurant
and you get it at the end they're gonna
say yeah that's why you're eating him
yeah [ __ ] because
somebody gave you a [ __ ] gift yeah so
that was always out the door
never that me and my girl and my people
were at restaurants i would
put that [ __ ] away or she would give it
to me i'll be like yeah i'll use it i'll
put it in my pocket
and i'll [ __ ] pick cats [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] you know what i mean
just because you're highly aware of like
what these people are thinking about
yeah for sure
i i already have that i already feel
that you know people are the way you
know they think so i'll be like [ __ ]
that i'm gonna show them different
when i walk up in this place pushing
stereotype yeah boundaries
yes yes for sure i get like that's what
i say like when i'm around when i go
certain spots and there's like
doctors and you know i know there's some
people that are doctors i just you know
assume i go these my books are probably
doctors do you know me
but i just say [ __ ] that that's who
started this [ __ ] with me you know as a
kid
that took my dreams away what i wanted
to be you know what i mean like i wanted
to be a cop as a kid you know
like [ __ ] that was my dream you know
what i mean but when this [ __ ]
told me
take that [ __ ] out of your head you're
gonna be you need to [ __ ]
get some brains that work in an office i
was like [ __ ] that i don't want to work
in an office
so [ __ ] i mean i get it so you're
throwing money down to be like [ __ ] you
guys i get that
i'm only talking about the times we go
to the restaurant we're not going to
mention and the
[ __ ] waiters are always whack as hell
this little tips and fangirl bro
i'm [ __ ] irritated oh that's for to
let them know
that's actually that's to let them know
oh i get that sometimes it happens twice
at the same time
it's such a city such a shitty [ __ ]
[ __ ] mentality
way to think about it okay i know what
you're saying you lost a train of
thought i can see it in your face are
you ready
since the sensation is such a [ __ ]
shitty [ __ ] um
service you know customer service
[ __ ] i want to say that [ __ ]
that's what i'll do when they give a
shitty
customer service the best thing to do is
[ __ ] you know
i get it kill him with some [ __ ] i
get it no i'm talking about when they're
rude [ __ ] i'm gonna give you
something that's gonna [ __ ] make you
think about what
i get it because if you're nice i'll tip
you even if your service was dog [ __ ]
if you're a nice person if you were nice
and you were actually nice to this and
you weren't like oh what's up
what'd you want okay like [ __ ] this guy
you get like nfl dudes coming in and not
tipping and [ __ ] too though yeah
oh yeah no for sure but i'm just saying
like when they see already like
exactly like if they see they didn't get
tipped by this [ __ ] dude that's a
[ __ ]
nfl player you know what i mean didn't
[ __ ] tip [ __ ] [ __ ]
and they see me what the [ __ ] are they
going to next remember that no of course
we understand we understand it so so
with that being said
it's like with them being so pissed off
and giving me such a shitty [ __ ]
customer service
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna [ __ ]
hook them up so next time
they realize that the next [ __ ]
that walks in that looks like me i'm
gonna make it better for him
so here you go here's 100 bucks bam take
that and think about it
that's why you do that you know i get
that that's paying it forward
and if don't be a [ __ ] way yeah exactly
i get it it's going to remember
him he's going to remember me for sure
yeah but you go back to the same
restaurants all the time i'm saying i'm
just not going back to restaurant
i get your mentality it's awesome and
but the thing is me like
hey i give it a [ __ ] weed money [ __ ]
you
but your mentality is [ __ ] on him
even harder with niceness
i get that ready can you tell me why
you're not allowed in certain casinos in
l.a
don't say which ones why did you get
kicked out of the casino i got 86 from a
bunch
from now about you i gotta get you six
from a casino
actually you know what casino [ __ ]
love my ass man [ __ ] but hold on
why did you get why'd you get kicked out
for life
if you could tell this in under three
minutes
so what would you tell me if i was
somebody right now saying hey
what's the craziest thing you've ever
done a casino tell them that story what
happened
[ __ ] just it was wild man [ __ ] wild ass
[ __ ] bro just
uh [ __ ] i don't know what t what was
that [ __ ]
i know why you got kicked out of a
casino can you tell the audience why you
got kicked out the casino for life
because i know the story um to me it
still wasn't such a bad thing i think it
was the best baby
[ __ ] that was so i mean i had all my
boys we're gonna go drink watch the game
there and [ __ ] and uh
let's see what was it i think we were
two there for a minute they [ __ ] uh
this
so anyway so all my boys get there we
all asked for a drink my boys actually
got there i was there from
maybe about i started about drinking
about one o'clock i think we were
playing the phillies it was an early
game
and uh i forgot to script it right now a
couple of my friends came in
after like at four o'clock so i was
already drunk but so i asked for a round
of drinks for all my friends and um
ran a bill up ran a bill for sure you
know but they gave us a [ __ ]
they started giving us all plastic cups
you know a beer in the price of cubs and
[ __ ] and this was
[ __ ] you know it was commerce casino you
know what i mean [ __ ] you make [ __ ]
hella money i said without insane names
but keep going are you gone
oh we can't
give us all our beers and plastic cups
so i'm like [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] i
thought of my casino i'm not the [ __ ]
let me [ __ ] swap me bro you know what
i mean the [ __ ] you know
and everybody else had glass cups though
yeah everybody else had glass cuffs
that's why we had all plastic cups i was
like
[ __ ] this brothers hate to swap me bro
get [ __ ] give me my glass cubs you
know me
so we made them switch off all the beers
brought us [ __ ] glass cups
[ __ ] next thing you know we're all
drinking and [ __ ] you know
they have a new floor manager it's just
a [ __ ] little piece of [ __ ]
and uh [ __ ] you know to this day i
think yeah i remember
[ __ ] no neck [ __ ] what did
you do you you little [ __ ] no neck
[ __ ] tell them why
[ __ ] tell them why uh [ __ ]
it was it was crazy but that was crazy
[ __ ] they just
they decided to [ __ ] throw us out i
don't know because
i was like trying to get the story out
of this kid like why did you get
expelled
tell me the stories actually so we had a
big tab bro and this guy was like
[ __ ] like you guys are [ __ ]
you guys are out of here they paid they
ran up such a large bill they were gonna
pay for that they kicked them the [ __ ]
out and said you guys aren't gonna pay
and as they're kicking them out they
figure out my bill tab and they go don't
kick them out make them pay first
yeah i understand why would they just
ask you to pay for the show actually
what it was was a new
a new floor man came in it was his
senior ship crazy
a new ship came in and [ __ ] he didn't
realize
that you know he figured like who's
going to pay for all these [ __ ] beers
you know what i mean
once again they're looking at you going
this guy's trouble you know huh
yeah he got rid of me has every as he's
getting rid of me time to get the [ __ ]
out of the casino like to leave already
i'm like all right cool let's leave as
they were getting up they're like
no someone tells the managers the the
floor manager hey
check this out look at his bill and
that's he's all like no
no no come here and that's when he
stopped me in a minute he's like
you need to pay your bill before you go
on i'm just like
what bill i'm like oh [ __ ] that bill i'm
like [ __ ] so the [ __ ] bill was
[ __ ] it was up there man
it was from me actually from like maybe
12 in the afternoon one o'clock in the
afternoon to like
eight o'clock at night seven o'clock
tonight so these two racks at least uh
it wasn't
that much i want to say 14. i think
that's 17. okay
17 something you know what i mean i'm
beer you know it was just all beers and
[ __ ] just appetizers
[ __ ] hot wings and fries and [ __ ]
you know i mean me treating you know
everybody right there
so i remember when [ __ ] you just like
you need to leave you gave me a lot of
money i feel like like relax over two
years yeah it wasn't actually a lot of
money they were gonna
pay them i wanna say just the way the
way i look you know i mean that's a
crazy
just gives a whole different vibe you
know what i mean they see my look and
they automatically think [ __ ] watch
the door you're gonna run you know
you know this fool [ __ ] but the gang
you are
connected or some [ __ ] you know but
[ __ ] he stopped you in the middle
stopped me [ __ ] told me [ __ ] i had
to pay the bill
and they're paying the bill right before
i handed him the bill [ __ ] i throw it
in the farm while you pick it up you
[ __ ] know
no neck [ __ ] i mean and he
[ __ ] got pissed and i remember he
[ __ ]
they [ __ ] brought [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] security team came
and it was funny because i knew [ __ ]
most of them security they all [ __ ]
love my ass you should go there
all the time i was there [ __ ] i
practically lived there yeah i mean
at home we didn't mention that this folk
is a regular yeah
so are they [ __ ] stupid i don't
understand it was just that new floor
manager that just happened to go
in there that just [ __ ] you know what
it was what i figured out was that um
before that
before he became a floor manager he was
actually uh
he was like a busboy or something like
that and i think [ __ ]
i might have uh i might have
disrespected him by smoking weed in his
face
no i think i might have disrespected him
by um
but you know just by him being stupid
maybe not [ __ ] you know i maybe
ordered something on the phone [ __ ] he
didn't come through with it so i was
like yeah you [ __ ] out of here you
[ __ ] know
whatever sounds like something he said
something specific cause he's saying
i might
is what he's saying because i remember i
remember seeing him in a red suit and
then before you know it
he was like now like [ __ ] in like
black suit and look more like a manager
type
so you threw his money on the ground i
threw his money i'm like here he's like
oh you want your money
and he was all happy gaining with his
hand right before he [ __ ] put in his
hand i [ __ ] throw the front and go
now you [ __ ] pick it up
pick your [ __ ] money up i want it and
then you left he laughed at me he smiled
at me he picked it up but he went back
and
[ __ ] 86 me wow so about i want to say
about a week later
i went back and [ __ ] all security was
around me but they were like they were
cool as [ __ ] with me because they're
like
well you know what i mean like what
happened you know they want you they
want to take you down to the office and
it's like the end of america so i went
in there i went to the office and [ __ ]
they were like
they were like uh who are you i'm like i
don't know they told me to come in here
and
she's looking to a computer she's like i
don't know who you are i guess
face recognition didn't wasn't there yet
so many casinos i mean they had love for
me in a casino
for sure you know what i mean i already
had one at jackpot and i already have
i want to jog me and my girl wanted
jackpot there once and i went you know
literally to the top and i literally
went
tipping every single person i mean i'm
talking from the highest because
for some reason i guess in their
religion they or whatever religion they
were like i don't know what they were
but they feel you know they get some of
your money
you're giving them part of that look
that you just got oh good [ __ ] so they
were cool as [ __ ] with me everybody in
that casino
that one guy ruined their money this guy
[ __ ] ruined it for me when i went in
there they're like we don't know who you
are what's up and
finally this one guy comes oh yeah
dodger
dodger jersey on this day on this date
and he types in stuff
oh yeah i got you oh yeah you're 86. and
next thing you know that little short
[ __ ] comes in
and he starts saying yeah um he's the
one that's an animal
he came in he's like oh there's the guy
right here that was that [ __ ]
disrespected the
the bar and this man and the lady goes
yeah i'm sorry but unfortunately we got
you right here
profanity you know use bad language
and then i go bad language i go no i
didn't and
she goes it says right here and i go no
i go this [ __ ] short naked
and then you see you just yelling he
just [ __ ] caught him a [ __ ] short
neck
i go this [ __ ] shot and i go bro i go
what's your problem man i go are you
really gonna [ __ ] do me like that
it's just a [ __ ]
back and forth [ __ ] fine i go you know
what [ __ ] it i'm 86 [ __ ] it i go
you know maybe for a reason i'm out of
here and [ __ ] i stepped out of there and
i
should not it's been about over eight
years
a year seven years i haven't stepped
foot back in that casino don't get me
wrong you know what i stepped foot about
maybe three years after that me and my
girl just went in there after dodging
we're
[ __ ] and we're drunk and it was after
three in the morning and they literally
they let us go in and they let us go in
because they figured we don't sell
alcohol so this guy's not going to come
here and drink so
he's [ __ ] he's either going to come
here and spend money so [ __ ] i went in
there
ship straight to the back rack [ __ ]
put on dragon
and said [ __ ] give me the dragon hit
dragon one
one i think like [ __ ] 2500 bucks
walked right out five minutes and we're
walking out we're looking at the cameras
and we're laughing at the cameras
like yeah stupid you know cause
don't get us wrong we [ __ ] up we're so
drunk that we did walk to the bar and
we're like can i get a beer and they're
like bars clothes like
we're like [ __ ] you know so we went
straight to the table
[ __ ] one walked right on we're like
[ __ ] yeah you know what i mean so
that was the last time ever since then
[ __ ] and i went back to that place
so commerce casino many of you out there
there short neck guy
[ __ ] off also let lg back in oh actually
don't stop don't be gambling
put that money towards something else
[ __ ] that [ __ ] um that's that's one of
the questions
i wanted to do and i have one more
i have one more question for you yeah
should i call you mr tick-tock
mr tick-tock
explain explain man that's [ __ ] now
you're taking that [ __ ] to
[ __ ] 1981 or 82 [ __ ]
that's when breakdancing was wrong it
was your name
yeah yeah so my cousins same ones that
were gang members before they were into
the break dancing
like i said they were probably more into
it more they brought that little culture
around you know [ __ ]
breakdancing was like the [ __ ] you know
i mean [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] beach street came out
and all that [ __ ] so it was like a
[ __ ]
something to do so my cousin was they
were back then people would make cats
and they would have you know whatever
your
your special weather your special move
was [ __ ] that was your name
you know you're [ __ ] mr roberts
wearing shirts like this big
like small no but i remember the baggy
sweaty pat the bag
the baggy sweatpants [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] bandana [ __ ] over your knees
and [ __ ] in case you had a dude and
you're six years younger so you're a
little like
[ __ ] i'm talking about them
i was made about [ __ ] man five six
years old damn
so i was just [ __ ] seeing them you
know i mean i was like [ __ ] it you know
i
mean
so [ __ ] one day they were they were
right there break dancing and i'm right
there trying to [ __ ] you know mimic
them [ __ ] trying to do the same [ __ ]
and for some reason [ __ ] i [ __ ]
did it bro i did the
[ __ ] tick tock you know what i mean
[ __ ] [ __ ]
not the app my cousin was like [ __ ] you
oh i'm gonna get you a hat
[ __ ] you mr tick tock and [ __ ] you they
gave me a hand i was just a little kid
rocking the hat
but [ __ ] i remember [ __ ] my dad didn't
let me support that [ __ ] like oh
yeah you [ __ ] way no [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that
and my dad was straight [ __ ] but not
on your older brother he let him wear it
no same [ __ ] at the time no [ __ ] no same
[ __ ] you know what i mean
[ __ ] take that [ __ ] off you know what
i mean nothing
if you wouldn't so the reason i bring
this up
is because some of you in this in this
thumbnail might have thought
that kind of just looks like dog face
with [ __ ] glasses on
all right so that dog face guy before he
got super popular he used to see him on
tick tock and i'd go
hey full it's you you're dancing
and then he goes that ain't me shut the
[ __ ] up fool shut up
and then he got hella popular and this
food was like
now people think that's me no that ain't
me i don't dance cause he don't dance
and [ __ ]
no no hate against him it's mad about
dancing my dm i'm saying me like
damn for you i thought that was really
you
his name yeah mr tick tock and he was a
dancer
too much it's full circle and it's not
even you how
crazy is that [ __ ] that's why i had to
throw it out there
mr [ __ ] did you say you always used
to facetime you and [ __ ]
like so about a year before that dog
phase even came out before tick tock
came out
every time i facetimed this guy he would
make it a mission to be drinking
something different as he answered
randomly random you know if i have the
pictures we'll throw them up all over
the screen all right
this will randomly but it was always
ocean spray mo
mainly and how and i was like this
motherfucker's take
he took your whole identity oh gee
cram grape looking like you mr tick tock
i would get to [ __ ] with this for you i
mean yeah it's funny it's funny you know
like
i put my friends in the freezer here i
am i want to drink a [ __ ] advertise
this
so i'll put most of the main camera
mostly on yeah like that whatever it was
a little bit on my face just to be like
every time [ __ ] it like a year and a
half wow
and then started turning to deodorants
and random [ __ ]
and they just stopped doing it but the
reason i bring it oh
i'd like to put my friends in the
freezer so i i press open
i like answer call close it and i'll
open it
what's up because it's just like what
the [ __ ] just happened to me
because because you feel like you're in
the freezer i do that with you with my
weak closet
he did that do that with me in the wheat
closet was that right yeah
i think i did that one time i was at
home depot this people got me in the
store
you know i'm all like [ __ ] i put it back
i put it in there i had to like close
the fridge
in a store behind like yo that [ __ ] my
brain up
yo mr tick tock yo dude it's been two
and a half hours good job
[ __ ] you didn't you didn't do a backflip
you didn't start breakdance you did
nothing two and a half hours
good [ __ ] that's good if you want you
could do a windmill
mineral windmill right here on the table
on the table
[ __ ] i could never do the windmill bro i
wasn't
mr windmill that was the toughest bro if
you could do the windmill back in the
days [ __ ] you're a badass and i'm a
[ __ ] bro i should do a head spin
i can only do one and a half as long as
i ever did it but i would do it like
and hold my hands close so i didn't like
oh i was a kid
i used to wear a beanie i sucked i tried
to do the cardboard once and went it but
it moves under you
and that was it i got into that [ __ ] for
[ __ ]
two weeks i swear to god um
all right so for everyone let's let's
let's uh at the end of this
let's do this for everyone out there
maybe law enforcement this fool's not a
drug deal anymore he
is a legal drug dealer now and he runs a
shop
here in la it's probably the biggest
shop yeah it is
it's the biggest shop yeah so this full
manager is the biggest shop now i'm
gonna show the podcast a ton of [ __ ]
love
yo every time we walk into dtbg guys
it's one of our videos on it's so fun
the first time it happened
what because i could see my own face but
it was i thought it was a reflection but
i was in the [ __ ] tv way back there
it's a huge wall this big was just it's
my face
weird it was cool it was weird i never
appreciate that show yeah so um yeah
yeah that was one of my dreams come true
you know yep run in the [ __ ] shop
dude
you guys have seen on the dope dobasil
channel many times um so if you see og
say uh
what up [ __ ]
check it out and we're not advertising
we're not advertising in any way to go
check out a shop
all right youtube we're just saying this
is the shop he runs for everyone out
there he's not a [ __ ] drug dealer
they don't kick his door and think he's
got packs
that's a long time ago okay i have to
always say that cuz i want my friends
being like
oh i know where that fool is but all
you're gonna find is [ __ ] playstation
five
nice still get hit up man [ __ ] left and
right [ __ ]
packs and get this and get that i was
like [ __ ]
no i just think [ __ ] it it's been too
long to even
try them two answers it's like foot it's
ridiculous not worth it so stop dm and
all that [ __ ]
we cannot put links inside of the
youtube
i don't put links to certain youtubes i
mean i don't put my link to uh
dopagillo.com in our video descriptions
because it shows we
videos so even though i show weed videos
on youtube
links are scary so i cannot put your
instagram
in the description because it's nothing
but like
crazy pounds or joints it'll be on joe
buzzilla.com it'll be on doublezeal.com
but for everyone out there that wants to
follow instagram it's og
kush so og ee kush
76 that's his instagram go ahead and
follow it pop up i just tried to tag him
that [ __ ] is not easy to find his burner
account comes up first
yeah he had a he got deleted yeah he had
to leave me once i got it back and [ __ ]
yeah so go ahead and check it out guys
that's his instagram
actually i'm gonna [ __ ] do a very
poor job with it but
i've been trying to tell this full to
post for six years
uh-huh i got something what does it say
oh i just need to transfer these things
off my computer i got a bunch of
pictures
you've been saying that [ __ ] i've
been trying to help this [ __ ] do
his instagram forever
he's still using this posting i'm gonna
be posting some [ __ ] you have to now
right now for everyone out there on
spotify and apple and youtube you guys
heard it og quiz 76 oh g
e e kush76 go write a comment go hey
[ __ ] post
don't say [ __ ] but like hey you
should post more let's just go right
there no no hey
i'm starting to go live a little bit
more so i mean this feels so
inactive on this instagram but it's all
good it's just fun we [ __ ] this one does
crazy we [ __ ] so do more of it
what the [ __ ] i got you i want to take
care of you guys thank you
um guys uh two hours and 40 minutes man
good job you're over here like i don't
know
i don't know and look at we did almost
three [ __ ] hours
good [ __ ] good job yeah no actually you
guys can tease and take his glasses off
his eyes have been closed the whole
[ __ ] time
he's just been like this the whole time
yeah
how are my eyes closed like you know
when you're on a [ __ ] roller coaster
you can't wait till it ends
or a plane like from the 100 000
shopping spree
um okay thank you guys thank you fool
appreciate it
um we take another shot rosie's gonna
pick me up so i don't gotta
uber you back so i can get a little
[ __ ] up right now [ __ ] it appreciate
you having me
thank you for finally coming on the show
thank you guys
uh you ask so [ __ ] much here it is oh
gee
uh pasqual i don't know if you want
anybody to say that but
it's kind of hard not to be like oh gee
and just leave it there
so as og thank you for uh coming on the
show
you talked about a lot of [ __ ] good i'm
i'm happy
because you hate talking on camera and
you really talk today this was like
another inadvertent interview with the
drug dealer
dude it was good except you actually
talk because you don't talk on cameras
people say
950 words to me camera goes
[Music]
he just turns like a little bug
i'm telling you well i'm not lying
you're fine it was good good [ __ ]
um thank you for coming on the show i
appreciate you guys thank you so much
for watching
this has been the dope as usual podcast
thank you guys so much for watching if
you're in the car driving
please be safe if you're at home with
your homies thank you for smoking it up
if you're at school or work
thank you for letting us help you pass
the time all right thank you man
appreciate let's smoke some more weed
guys thank you so much for watching for
me marty you know gee uh have a dope ass
day
be safe i'll talk to you guys next week
oh
next week get ready felipe esparza
next guest felipe esparza we're going to
start telling you guys which guests are
coming next
just so you get a feel of what the [ __ ]
to come all right funny ass felipe
esparza next week
have a dope ass day all right good job
man
all right good [ __ ]
damn you got indentions from those
glasses give me a shot brody
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]